Mike, mach mal einen Test jetzt.
Mach mal einen Test, sagst du mal kurz was rein?
Super, super.
Ja Das ist doch eine schöne Stelle zum drüber sprechen, oder? Sehr spacige Musik, aber es ist ja auch ein spaciges Thema. Es geht um Satelliten im Chaos Radio heute. Und bevor wir da auf Details eingehen und uns natürlich erstmal mit den allgemeinen Sachen beschäftigen, zum Beispiel weiß ich, Chaos Computer Club kann man alles fragen. Was ist die Übersetzung von Satellit? Drei Gesichter, mehr sind super. Nein, das ist absichtlich. Wir sagen es absichtlich nicht. Wir haben nämlich ein kleines Quiz vorbereitet. Wer im Chat zuerst uns mit Quellenangabe sagen kann, was die deutsche Übersetzung von Satellit ist und wo das herkommt, dieses Wort, der, der hat gewonnen.
Genau, für den denken wir uns was aus.
Kommt nämlich nicht oft vor, dass wir uns was ausdenken.
Satellit, ja Satellit fragt ihr mein, ja Satellit. Wo kommt das her, das Wort? Was bedeutet das auf Deutsch? Und den technischen Hintergrund, den bringen wir euch dann hier, oder?
Genau.
Tja, was ist das eigentlich? Ein Satellit. Kleines Metallhäufchen, was sich um die Erde dreht. Der erste Satellit, den es gab, das weiß sicherlich jeder, das war der Sputnik. Den haben die Russen hochgeschossen.
Und zwar nur um die Amis zu agern.
Genau, denn was anderes hat er ja auch nicht gemacht, oder?
Der flog halt einfach um die Erde und machte Piep, Piep, Piep.
Und nur Piep.
Die Vorlage für moderne Pop-Songs, sozusagen.
Ja, naja, es war halt damals so, dass das Wettrennen in den Weltall noch nicht gestartet war, dass alle so ein bisschen dran forschten und keiner damit rechnete, dass irgendjemand tatsächlich der Erste sein könnte. Und die Amerikaner waren dann tatsächlich ziemlich geschockt, dass 1957 da irgendwas um die Erde flog und Piep, Piep machte, weil letztendlich ging es nicht darum, dass es um die Erde flog, sondern dass es auch an irgendeinem beliebigen Punkt runterfallen konnte und dass es eigentlich vielleicht nicht nur Piep, Piep machen könnte, sondern auch BUM, wenn es runterfällt.
Satellit, Begleiter eines Planeten, auch Mond genannt, Mayas Handlexikon. Aber wo kommt es sprachlich her? Hat Civi geschrieben? Civi, dann in Uniform nächste Sendung hier melden. Entschuldigung, dass ich es unterbrochen hab, Frank. Ich muss natürlich hier gucken, wenn jetzt wirklich jemand schnell im Chat ist, dann muss ich unterbrechen. Ihr könnt ja gewonnen haben. Mayas Handlexikon ist natürlich irgendwie Begleiter eines Planeten.
Naja, ich meine, es ist ja keine unzertreffende Bezeichnung. Das Bemerkenswerte an dem Satelliten ist eben, dass er nicht, geht natürlich mittlerweile auch für Weltraumstationen, aber das Bemerkenswerte ist, dass er ja nicht irgendwie mit einem, primär mit einem Antrieb irgendwie durch die Gegend fliegt, wo er hin und hin möchte, sondern dass er sich eigentlich wunderbar auf die Erdanziehungskraft einstellt und in Abhängigkeit der Höhe und sozusagen eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit erreicht. Da können wir uns auch nochmal ein paar Quiz draus machen, aus diesem, ihr wisst schon, was ich meine. Auf jeden Fall waren die Russen vorneweg. Die haben diesen Sputnik hochgeschossen und das hat irgendwie den Amerikanern überhaupt nicht gepasst, wie das immer so ist, wenn die Russen irgendwie den Fuß vorne hatten.
Da gab es den sogenannten Sputnik-Schock in den USA, wo die Sicherheitspolitiker sich die Haare ausrauchten und ihre Wissenschaftler verzweifelt fragten, wieso waren wir nicht die ersten und die Wissenschaftler, die mit den Nilfeldknuten zurück in die Labors getrieben wurden, um schnellstmöglich so ein Stück Metall um die Erde fliegen und Pipipen anzulassen.
Aber so richtig getan hat er ja eigentlich nichts, ne?
Er war halt oben und hat Pip gemacht.
Ich meine, hat er was runtergefunkt?
Ich glaube, er hat eigentlich nichts weiter getan als Pip zu machen. Also es war schon unten Kot, aber mir ist gerade nicht mehr so richtig erinnert, was für ein Kot das war.
Also es war Telemetrie, das ist die Energie, dass er noch hat.
Ich glaube, irgendwie so was war es, wie viel Strom noch in der Batterie war.
Wir rufen einige Leute an, mal gucken, ob da jemand die genaue Bezeichnung von Satellit weiß. Im Chat kommt nämlich nicht viel. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Christoph Niedern.
Christoph, hallo. Wolltest du was zum Thema Satelliten sagen? Sag mal.
Also Satellit, ich würde sagen, das ist lateinisch. Bedeutete wie Trabant.
Spitzel.
Und was ist Trabant für eine Sprache?
Na, das ist Deutsch, hoffe ich doch.
Also auf Ostdeutsch könnten wir uns einigen.
Ja, Trabant stimmt natürlich auch, klar. Aber es ist nicht wirklich die Übersetzung von Satellit, nehme ich mal an. Christoph, wir hören noch mal weiter. Wer ist denn da? Hallo.
Hallo, hier ist Hannes.
Hannes, weißt du, was es richtig übersetzt heißt?
Also er hat schon recht, das ist lateinisch.
Also lateinisch heißt es Bacillus und bedeutet Leibwächter.
Ach, guck an.
Also und der beschützt dann halt unsere Erde.
Leibwächter. Wo hast du das her? Stimmt das wirklich? Ah ja, der hatte ja in Latein immer eine Firma.
DTV und Erde.
Ich hatte kein Leibwächter.
Ja genau, kann noch jemand in so ein seriöses Lexikon kommen?
Ich finde Leibwächter klingt irgendwie überzeugend.
Gut.
Das wird schon stimmen.
Haben wir jetzt was gewonnen?
Nee. Wir wollen das Quiz ja noch durch die Sendung weiterführen.
Durch die Wände.
Durch die Wände, genau, da kommen wir jetzt drauf.
Gleich kommen wir jetzt zum Fritz-Kurz-Info. Wenn ihr also noch was langes erzählen wollt zum Satelliten-Thema, dann wartet ihr.
Eigentlich sind wir jetzt auch schon durch.
Sind wir durch. Okay, dann können wir den Rest der Sendung Musik spielen, das ist doch schön. Dann lass uns gleich jetzt das Kurz-Info machen und dann sprengen wir tiefer ein. Gehört Chaos Radio Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Das Thema heißt Satelliten Leibwächter. Wofür stand SOS nochmals? Satellites on Speed oder? Mehr davon, dann damn next.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Jetzt ist es nämlich erst mal 22.30 Uhr.
Waffenkontrollen, UN-Generalsekretär Anan bereitet die Inspektionen den acht irakischen Präsidenten Palästen vor. Die US-Regierung dringt darauf, das neue Abkommen mit Irak so bald wie möglich auf die Probe zu stellen. Kandidaten kür. Die SPD will einen Tag nach der Wahl in Niedersachsen über ihren Kanzlerkandidaten entscheiden. Parteichef Lafontaine hat den Vorstand für kommenden Montag zu einer Sondersitzung einberufen. Ablehnung. Das Landesparlament in Brandenburg ist gegen eine nachträgliche Änderung der Bodenreform von 1945. Den Alteigentümern dürfe der Rückkauf enteigneter Flächen nicht erleichtert werden, sonst seien die ostdeutsche Landwirtschaft und tausende Arbeitsplätze bedroht. Anstieg. Rechtsradikale begehen immer mehr Gewalttaten. Nach Erhebungen des Bundesverfassungsschutzes stieg die Zahl der Delikte im vergangenen Jahr um mindestens 10 Prozent. Prozess. Drei Monate nach dem Überfall auf einen 28-jährigen Ganaer in Potsdam hat die Staatsanwaltschaft Anklage erhoben. Wegen schwerer Körperverletzung müssen sich fünf Jugendliche vor Gericht verantworten.
Wette.
Nachts bewölkt, aber trocken um 5 Grad. Morgen lockert die Bewölkung noch mal wieder auf. Temperaturen bis 10 Grad.
Verkehr.
Keine Meldungen und gute Fahrt für euch.
Das war Gerhard Kötter-Heinrich mit den Fritz Kurz-Info. Warum schaffe ich es eigentlich nie, die Promo-Jingles einzustellen, bevor ich sie brauche? Ich verstehe es nicht.
Fritz wird fünf und präsentiert die Radioshow mit Mike Lehmann, Susanne, Tommy Walsch, Kutner, Comanche, der alten Frau, Ursul, The Glorious Fritz-File featuring Break and Film, Homo Space als Showband und...
Jo, hör dir das mal an hier.
Sabine Bullthaupt und Dietmar Wischmeier... Heißt das, dass sie dann alle auf der Bühne sind, so zum Sehen? Das ist ja gar nicht lustig. 5 Jahre Fritz-Radioshow. Samstag, 28. Februar in der Columbia-Halle. Danach gibt's die große 5 Jahre Fritz-Geburtstagsparty. Mit Maruscha, Dr. Motte, Markus Lopez, Olli Massif, Andre Langenfeld und anderen Fritz-Dj's. Die Fritz-Radioshow zum 5. Fritz-Geburtstag. Mit Party, Samstag, 28. Februar in der Columbia-Halle. Am Flughafen Tempelhof in Berlin. Karten gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt. Und beim Fritz-Mützen-Telefon. 0331 für Potsdam, 7097120. Und im März geht die Fritz-Radioshow auf Tournee durch Brandenburg. Wer nicht kommt, kann gleich zu Hause bleiben.
Ha, jetzt hab ich's.
Chaosradio geht weiter. Tim, du sollst mal Hans anrufen. Das mit dem Telechat funktioniert scheinbar nicht so richtig im Moment. Also vergess den erstmal für heute. Tja, müsst ihr halt doch den WWW-Chat benutzen. www.fritz.de Das Thema heute im Chaosradio, im Computer Blumen bei Fritz lautet, heißt, ist Satelliten. Ich glaube, ich habe Hans gerade beleidigt, weil ich gefragt habe, welcher Hans. Da kann ja im Chat irgendeiner Hans heißen.
Es gibt nur einen Hans.
Es kann nur einen Hans geben.
Okay, so die Russen hatten den ersten Satellit im All, haben wir gerade gehört, was die Amis nicht gerade begeistert hat.
Genau, dann haben die Amis angefangen, die Willen zu werkeln, um natürlich auch einen Satelliten hochzukriegen. Haben sie noch irgendwann geschafft und haben, genau wie die Russen, natürlich sofort erkannt, dass man von da oben halt prima Fotos machen kann. Und sie haben dann so in den frühen Monaten von 1960 hatten sie dann die ersten Erfolge damit, tatsächlich Satelliten in der Umlaufbahn zu schießen, die sie auch vorherbestimmen konnten. Und haben dann halt dieses sogenannte Corona-Programm gestartet. Das war das erste amerikanische Spionagesatelliten-Programm.
Was mit Bier betrieben war.
Ich glaube, dieses Bier wurde nach dem Spionageprogramm in Deutschland. Die brauchten echt eine Menge davon. Sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft, irgendwie nach 14 Versuchen zum ersten Mal da einen Satelliten hochzukriegen, der auch wieder Bilder nach unten brachte. Das muss man sich nicht so vorstellen, wie heute so Fernsehsatelliten mit einer Kamera obendrein und dann werden die Bilder runtergesendert. Nein, da ist ein großer Fotoapparat drin gewesen. Und dann kam halt in so einem Fall schon mit so einer Kapsel tatsächlich der Film runter. Und fiel dann irgendwo ins Meer und es soffelt manchmal ab. Und deswegen haben sie halt beschlossen, sie müssen jetzt noch eine Hightech entwickeln. Und zwar haben sie es geschafft, diese Kapsel am Fallschirm aufzufangen, bevor sie ins Meer gefallen ist.
Sollte es noch erwähnen, dass dieser Satellit irgendwie da eine lustige Neigung noch im Weltall macht, bevor er seine Kapsel abgeschmissen hat.
Ja, genau, stimmt. Der kippt ja noch so elegant runter.
Der kippt sich noch so elegant und wirft dann diese Kapsel runter. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele von diesen Kapseln hatte der da eigentlich drin?
Also die ersten Corona-Satelliten hatten nur eine Kapsel drin und die letzten, die sie hochgeschossen haben, hatten acht Kapseln drin. Und das Lustige an diesem Corona-Programm ist, dass es neulich als nicht mehr geheim gehalten klassifiziert wurde, vor anderthalb Jahren, glaube ich. Und dass man die Bilder aus diesem Programm mittlerweile käuflich erwerben kann bei den Amerikanern für relativ wenig Geld, ich glaube so acht Dollar pro Bild. Das Lustige war, die Satelliten flogen so rüber und haben immer so einen Streifen Film belichtet von dem Territorium, was da drunter lag. Und sie haben sich dann irgendwie große Mühe gegeben, irgendwie den Bau der Mauer zu fotografieren. Und haben dann irgendwie in großer Mühe noch irgendwie extra eine Rakete gebaut und die schneller zusammengefrickelt, als sie eigentlich normalerweise fertig sein sollte. Und hochgeschossen und dann hatten sie dann irgendwie einen Film runterbekommen und waren tierestolz, dass sie dann doch irgendwie...
Nachdem sie dreizehn Andäufe gebraucht haben, um das Ding überhaupt erstmal ins Weltall zu kriegen.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie es schon ein, zwei Mal geschafft. Und dann haben sie aber 1961 statt dem Mauerbau leider einige hundert Quadratkilometer Wolken fotografiert, weil es halt gerade wolkig war zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das finden sie ziemlich betrübsam. Das ist doch hübsch.
Der Himmel über Berlin.
Man kann sich diese Bilder im Internet auch angucken. Und sie haben tatsächlich ziemlich gute Auflösungen erreicht. Zum Schluss sind sie da bis auf drei Meter pro Pixel runtergekommen. Haben auch diverse Dinge neu erfunden. Nur irgendwann stellte sich halt raus, dass es irgendwie ziemlich unpraktisch ist, da einfach mal so Fotokapseln abzuschmeißen aus dem Ei, weil da muss man die auffangen und entwickeln und all diese Dinge.
Und wir wissen ja, wie lange das dauert, wenn man da die Satellitenfilme abgibt.
Entwickeln sie auch Satellitenfilme?
Wie?
Naja, und dann haben sie sich halt ein paar neue Gedanken gemacht.
Die Amerikaner.
Währenddessen haben die Russen natürlich auch ihre Satelliten gebaut. Bei den Russen ist es so ein bisschen...
Von wem war denn dieser Echo-Satellit? Also ich meine, der Witz war ja... Dieser Sputnik war ja eigentlich zu nichts anderem gut, als irgendwie mal zu gucken, wie das eigentlich so ist, wenn man so ein Stück Metall in die Umlaufbahn schickt.
Mit einer Batterie und einem Sender.
Richtig, aber er hat ja im Prinzip nur Statusmeldungen von sich gegeben und sonst einfach gar nichts. Also ein konkreter Nutzen, außer dass man das mal ausprobiert hat, war ja daraus noch nicht so. Ich finde es recht interessant, dass die Amis halt als allererstes sofort erstmal an Spionage gedacht haben. Dann werden wir ja auch noch tief reinsteigen in das Thema. Aber dieser Echo-Satellit...
Ja, das war doch ein Reflektionssatellit, ich denke. Das war einfach so, wie die Amateurfunker den Mond als natürlichen Satelliten benutzen, dass die da ihre Signale Richtung den Mond schicken und dass der an günstigen Konstellationen einfach das reflektiert.
Und reflektiert in der Mond.
Ja, das ist doch auch ein Satellit.
Also die, wie wir ja vorhin schon gehört haben...
Ich war mal, also ich hab mir mal anguckt, was diese Erde, Mond, Erde, Funker so machen und also die den Mond als Reflektionsbasis benutzen. Und das ist schon... Also ich würde es halt unter Grenzwissenschaften einsortieren. Das ist doch keine mittelesortierische Angelegenheit. Na ja klar, aber... Aber es geht.
Die Amis haben doch extra mit ihren Mondpferden da oben so ein paar Dinge gelassen, wo man...
Achso, die haben Reflektoren ausgelegt.
Die haben Reflektoren ausgelegt. Also diese Reflektionsgeschichten waren halt die ersten Versuchen, Satelliten für Kommunikation zu benutzen. Da kommen wir ein bisschen später drauf, glaube ich.
Oder früher?
Interessant ist, dass diese Möglichkeit, ein Objekt in der Umlaufbahn als Kommunikationsplattform zu benutzen, schon in den 40er Jahren ziemlich heiß diskutiert wurde, wo noch niemand wusste, dass man es überhaupt schafft, da irgendwas ins Weltall zu schießen. Da haben schon einige Leute ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht, was man machen kann, wenn man tatsächlich der einst mal irgendeinen Klopmental da oben hat.
Fällt uns ja auch einiges zu ein.
Übrigens, als du gerade gesagt hast, Batterien, kann man vielleicht einer drei Sätze dazu sagen, wie die Dinger überhaupt mit Strom versorgt werden?
Naja, Stromversorgung ist immer so ein heikler Punkt bei Satelliten.
Ist klar.
Es ist halt so wie auf so einem Flug, man hat nur eine begrenzte Menge Handgepäck dabei und kann auch schlecht irgendwie Handgepäck nachlegen. Die ersten Satelliten waren ganz klar mit Batterien bestückt, also einfach chemische Batterien. Genau, später kam man auf die Idee, dass man da doch Solarzellen nehmen könnte. Das Problem war, dass zum damaligen Zeitpunkt Solarzellen aus Selen bestanden und einen ziemlich geringen Wirkungsgrad hatten und doch ziemlich schnell kaputt ging. Und dann kam dann doch ziemlich bald die Idee auf, dass man da halt irgendwas hochschicken kann, was strahlt. Und da gibt es halt verschiedenste Varianten von atombetriebenen Stromquellen. Also von kleinen, kompakten Atomreaktoren, die sich nicht so bewährt haben. Was man heute in den militärischen Satelliten findet, sind halt Isotopenstromquellen. Das heißt, es ist halt einfach eine Menge eines bestimmten relativen Materials. Das zerfällt halt und dabei wird es halt richtig warm. Und aus dieser Wärme wird dann mit so einer Art umgekäppten Peltier-Element Strom gewonnen. Das Problem ist halt nur, wenn so ein Ding runterfällt, dann hat man da eine mittlere Sauerei.
Aber sie lassen sich schon was einfallen, damit das Ding Strom kriegt.
Da bin ich ja zufrieden. Ich hab mir schon Sorgen gemacht.
Das musst du einfach.
Ich vertraue da einfach auf die Technik.
Aber heute ist halt im Wesentlichen ein Solarpaneel. Was ja auch noch deine eigenen Probleme mit aufwirft, hat man ja... Wie hieß der Sattel? Hubble hatte doch glaube ich dieses Problem, dass sich seine Solarpaneele zunächst einmal nicht ausklappen ließen.
Das war das eine Problem.
Das andere Problem war, dass die Solarpaneele irgendwie bei der Erdumrundung immer so flap flap machten, weil sich halt da eine gewisse Spannung durch die Wärmausdehnung bildete. Und dass diesen ganzen Satelliten immer kräftig durchgerüttelt hat, wenn man gerade so einen entfernten Stern so ein paar Millionen Lichtjahre entfernt beobachten will. Das ist halt echt impraktisch, weil das ganze Ding immer so über halben Meter hin und her wackelt.
So, ob ich das dem WWW-Chat hier irgendwie so ein bisschen entnehme, scheint der Telnet-Chat halbwegs zu funktionieren, oder? Chaosradio ccc.de auf Port 23. Ach Mensch, probier's doch aus, mega. Nee, WWW ccc.de Port 23. Also wer ein Telnet-Programm hat, kann das mit www.ccc.de.23 dann im Telnet chatten. Das ist eine ganze Ecke schneller als im WWW. So und ihr könnt natürlich zum Thema Satelliten hier auch gerne anrufen. Unser Telefonnummer ist 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110. Und ich kann das auch nochmal professionell ankündigen.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
So wichtige Begriffe für Satelliten, die mit Satelliten zu tun haben, die werden wir alle erklären. Da braucht ihr also vielleicht erstmal nicht dafür anrufen. Administration steht hier noch auf meinem Ablaufzettel. Da stellt sich natürlich dann sowieso die Frage. Das wird ja demnächst in den nächsten Jahren werden ja massig kleinere Satelliten hier um diese Kugel rumkurven. Und da fragt man sich natürlich, wer das ist.
Ja, das ist ja schon so.
Ja, aber es werden immer mehr.
Naja, da werden wir gleich noch dann ein paar Minuten unseren Experten aus Amerika zu hören, der uns erklärt, wie das funktioniert, also wie diese Satelliten verwaltet werden.
Aber es ist es ist schon ein Problem. Vor allem gibt es schon ein echtes Schrottproblem, weil diese Satelliten sind natürlich sehr anfällig gegenüber Weltraumschrott und die USA zum Beispiel sind also kräftig dabei, nicht nur den Luftraum über ihrem Territorium auf Flugzeuge und Ähnliches zu untersuchen, sondern im Prinzip scannen sie halt den gesamten Orbit ab nach allem, was da in irgendeiner Form fliegt. Das hat natürlich erst mal ein klares militärisches Interesse. Abschraubengröße? Echt, wie kriegen die denn das gescannt?
Na, Radar.
Mit Radar, ja. Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Sie halten ihre Radarschüssel sozusagen ins Weltall und gucken halt mal, was da rumfliegt, weil eine Schraubengröße, so eine Schraube haut halt schon bei 20.000 kmh. Es gibt da auch ganz schön gute Löcher in so einen Satelliten rein. Also ich glaube, das macht NORAD. Ja, sowieso die Überwachung machen. Die scannen halt alles ab und von daher dürften die auch in etwa den Überblick haben, wie viele Satelliten es da tatsächlich gibt. Wir haben gesucht, wie die Blöden, wir haben irgendwie noch keine verlässliche Zahl gefunden. Wie viele es denn nun wirklich sein würden. Aber man kann davon ausgehen, eine ganze Menge. Denn so ein Satellit kostet heute nicht mehr viel. Ganz im Gegenteil, das ist eher noch so ein Abfallprodukt der Welt.
Was heißt denn das, der kostet nicht mehr viel?
Also der Zahlen, der letzte.
Ich habe jetzt mal die Zahlen von malaysischen Kommunikationssatelliten gesehen. Der Satellit Kodes kostet alleine 100.000, äh Quatsch, 100 Millionen. Dann das Launchen kostet 30 Millionen und die Versicherung, das hat mich irgendwie fasziniert, die hat 80 Millionen hingekostet.
Nimmst du zwei?
Nimmst du zwei. Geht doch billiger. Die TU hier in Berlin, die hat mal einen Satelliten gebaut, den PopSat-1, den haben sie zusammengeschwartet aus irgendwie ICER, Ikea, Regalteilen. Solarzellen, die sie irgendwie von Siemens geschnaut haben und dann halt so die üblichen westlichen Verbindungstechnologien, also Gaffa, Kabelbinder und Heißkleber. Und da haben sie halt irgendwie einen kleinen so ein Palmtop Computer reingeschraubt und ein kleiner Amateurfunkgerät und haben den halt irgendwie bei den Amerikaner und Russen mit hochgeschickt. Der heißt dann Flake.
Könnt ihr vielleicht einen Job bei Ikea besorgen? Es geht auch billig. Vor allem das Hochschießen ist im Prinzip ein Abfallprodukt, weil die stopfen halt irgendwie alles voll mit dem, was sie hochkriegen wollen. Und dann müssen sie einen bestimmten Ballastausgleich erzeugen. So und anstatt da einfach Blei rein zu tun, um das Idealgewicht sozusagen für den Flug zu bekommen, bieten sie eben irgendwelchen Universitäten oder so an, sozusagen weitgehend kostenlos diesen Startplatz mit zu benutzen.
Falls man sich also endgültig von seinem Hamster trennen will, kann man den auch mit hochschicken.
Dafür gibt es mittlerweile schon professionelle Dienstleistungen für die Beerdigung im Weltall. So hat man vielleicht auch erwähnt, Timothée Leary und mit wem ist er zusammen noch hoch?
Gene Roddenberry.
Und Gene Roddenberry, der seinerseits wiederum der Erschaffer der Star Trek-Series ist. Die sind ja mittlerweile nicht mehr unter uns, sondern sie sind deutlich über uns. Die haben sich nämlich einfach per Rakete ins Weltall befördern lassen und dann wurden sie da oben rausgekickt und kreisten eine Weile um die Erde, bis sie dann, glaube ich, ich weiß es schon wieder nicht, sind sie dann verblüht? Oder sind sie ins Weltall abgedrifftet?
Die sind immer noch oben und die verglühen dann irgendwann. Also sie kreisen da so drei Jahre rum. Eigentlich muss man dazu sagen, das ist ein bisschen irreführend. Die wären da nicht so, wie man es irgendwie so aus Star Trek kennt, so wie Spock denn da in seinem luxuriösen Sarg, da so aus der Torpedobucht gleitet, so es war das nicht, sondern da wurde halt die Asche, also ein Teil der Asche von den beiden Jungs irgendwie so auf Lippenstiftgröße zusammenkomprimiert und die fliegt dann halt da oben. Also gab da irgendwie wohl eine bestimmte Mindestgröße, wo es Norad darum gebeten hat, dass sie die einhalten, damit sie die halt noch trecken können. Und deswegen musste halt auch ein bestimmtes Metallvolumen dabei sein, damit sie die halt auf dem Screen behalten können, weil die fürchteten halt schon, dass sie demnächst sich da ein paar Zehntausend Leute oben BRD gelassen, und würde teilweise schlecht sogar in den Orbits, wo sie ihre Spionagesatelliten haben. Das wäre halt schon eine extrem unpraktische Angelegenheit.
Also auch das möglich, wenn wir mal gucken, was schon irgendwelche Fragen da sind. Na, da garantiert nicht. Das war ein Satellitengespräch. Hallo? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Ah, jetzt, hallo. Warte mal, nochmal anrufen. 7097110 in Potsdam. Thema sind Satelliten. Gut, jetzt haben wir einen kleinen Ausflug gemacht in Weltalbe-Bestattungen.
Wir waren gerade bei dem...
Wer hat sich im Weltalbe bestatten zu lassen? Ich glaub, die Adresse, die Firma heißt Celestis. www.celestis.com www.celestis.com Da kann man sich gleich irgendwie auch den Antrag als pdf runterladen.
Kostet irgendwie 5000 Dollar ungefähr, das war relativ preiswert eigentlich.
Genau, dann kann man sozusagen auch als Satellit die Erde begleiten, gleich ein rechter Spiel.
Aber wir waren eigentlich gerade bei Spionagesatelliten, glaube ich.
Darauf wollen wir hinaus.
Ja, wir waren bei den Corona-Satelliten. Die Corona-Satelliten waren sozusagen der erste ziemlich erfolgreiche Versuch von den Amis, ihre Spionageaktivitäten ins Weltall auszudehnen. Was halt dazukam, so zeitlich war, dass genau 1960 ja auch das Spionageflugzeug mit dem Powers, die U2, über der Sowjetunion abgeschossen wurde, sodass die Amis zu diesem Zeitpunkt keine Möglichkeit mehr hatten, an Luftaufnahmen von der Sowjetunion zu kommen, was sie doch ziemlich betrübt hat. Deswegen haben sie ihren Wissenschaftler noch mal einen richtigen Tritt in den Hintergrund gegeben, dass sie noch ein bisschen schneller arbeiten.
Das funktioniert dann bemerkenswerterweise auch immer ganz gut.
Die schmeißen da glaube ich auch viel Geld drauf. Die Nachfolger von diesen Corona-Programmsatelliten, das bis 1972 ging, waren die sogenannten Keyhole Class-Satelliten. Also Keyhole steht für Schlüsselloch. Die waren größtenteils auch noch Non-Real-Time, also Fotosatelliten, die dann die Kapseln runtergeschmissen haben, bis zum KH11. Also der Keyhole 11-Satellit ist der derzeit aktuelle Satellit und der kann...
In welchem Zeitraum reden wir denn? Also seit wann?
Also die Entwicklung der Keyhole Class-Satelliten begann so Anfang der 70er Jahre. Also der letzte Corona-Satellit hieß schon KH9, also Keyhole 9. Und die Bauform von den Satelliten blieb danach im Wesentlichen gleich. Also die wurden nur noch 1911 erweitert. Aber das Innenleben wurde doch sichtlich nach vorne gebracht. Also man kann sich so einen modernen Spionagesatelliten vorstellen, ungefähr wie dieses Hubble Teleskop. Also es ist halt ein großer Spiegel mit einer Optik davor. Der Spiegel reflektiert halt in allen möglichen Spektralfarben, soweit es irgendwie geht mit der Physik. Und da sind dann halt große CCD-Sensoren, die das Bild aufnehmen. Also wie der CCD-Sensor in einer heimatlichen Videokamera nur halt irgendwie mit deutlich größeren Abmessungen. Und die Auflösungen, die man mit den modernen Spionagesatelliten hinbekommt, liegen im Bereich unter 15 cm pro Pixel, den man da so sieht.
Das ist das, was derzeit bestätigt ist.
So, also man kann davon ausgehen, dass es auch noch darunter ist. Man bekommt dann schon Probleme mit der Luftzirkulation. Also wenn man von da oben aus einer großen Höhe runterguckt und irgendwie noch ein Nummernschild lesen will, wie es aus diversen Kinofilmen bekannt ist, dann hat man schon das Problem, dass das Luftflurren zu stark ist durch die viele Atmosphäre, die man da so durchsitzt.
Also vielleicht kann man das mal ein bisschen anschaulicher sagen. 15 Quadratzentimeter pro Pixel, das heißt...
15 mal 15 Zentimeter sozusagen.
Das sind dann aber nicht 15 Quadratzentimeter, da muss ich leider ein bisschen klugscheißen.
Hab ich doch nicht gesagt, ich hab 15 Zentimeter pro Pixel gesagt.
Ach, guck an. Gut, dann zieh ich meine Klugscheißrad zurück. Ich dachte, ihr könnt mal was Schlaues sagen.
Also wir meinen halt eine Fläche von 15 mal 15 Zentimetern. Wie viel ist jetzt ausgerechnet? Und das wird sozusagen als ein digitaler Bildpunkt, als ein Pixel dargestellt. Ich weiß nicht, was machen die? Wahrscheinlich 24 Bit. Interessanter, weil die nehmen ja auch nicht nur Bilder auf, sondern die sind sehr breitbandige Frequenzgeschichte. Die machen auch Infrarotbilder. Das ist auch sehr wichtig, weil mit Infrarot kann man eben einiges erkennen, was man optisch nicht erkennen kann. Panzer zum Beispiel im Wald, die verstecken sich optisch ganz prima unter den Bäumen. Da würde man sie ja nicht kriegen, aber sie fallen halt irgendwie, da sie ja eine Betriebswärme haben, mit einer Infrarotkamera sehr viel mehr auf.
Also diese Multispektralgeschichten...
Vielleicht sollten wir jetzt mal auf diese Technologie, dieser Abtaster eingehen.
Wie wir vielleicht aus dem Physikunterricht wissen, teilt sich der Licht in mehrere Wellenlängen auf. Also von Ultraviolett, das was den Haltkrebs macht, bis Infrarot, das was man so aus seiner Rotlichtbirne kriegt. Und dazwischen befindet sich halt das sichtbare Licht. Und all diese Bereiche haben halt, also alle Lichtbereiche, auch im sichtbaren und im unsichtbaren Bereich, haben halt spezifische Abbildungen auf diesen Sensoren, die halt dazu führen, dass man zum Beispiel Panzer gut erkennen kann im Infrarotbereich, wenn er im Wald steht, dass man aber zum Beispiel Menschen am besten erkennen kann in bestimmten anderen Spektralbereichen und so weiter und so fort.
Wobei das natürlich jetzt nicht nur benutzt wird bei Spionagegeschichten, sondern das ist auch natürlich sehr, sehr wichtig bei Landvermessungen. Damit kann man eben auch mit den Infrarotanteilen, kann man bestimmte Wasserflächen herausfiltern, also man kann eben schon klar erkennen, wo...
Erdbeben vorhersagen.
Erdbeben vorhersagen?
Ne, das machen sie meistens mit Radarsatelliten, aber...
Also Vulkanausbrüche meinst du? Gibt's da Wärme, spürbare Wärmekonzentration? Naja, logisch, wenn da irgendwie die Lava hochquält.
Ganz offensichtlich, muss man erstmal draufkommen.
Sollen wir kurz ins Telefon gehen? Ab und zu zwischendurch checken, ob da Leute dran sind, weil wenn wir die Nummer durchsagen, müssen wir auch reden. Hallo, wer ist da? Keiner! Tschüss, die legen dann alle auf, wenn man rangeht. Das ist so lustig, Telefon ist so eine Faszination für sich. Wir müssen ja immer wieder eine Telefonsendung machen.
Steht ja.
Steht an.
Steht an. In zwei Monaten.
Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110. Ihr müsst ein bisschen Geduld mitbringen, wenn ihr rankommen wird. Jetzt zum Beispiel seid ihr ganz schnell dran. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo? Hallo?
Irgendwas machen wir falsch.
Kannst du mich hören?
Dies ist ein Satellitengespräch.
Oh, Kinder, ihr müsst auch so simple Sachen wie ich sagen.
Johnny, ich gewinne langsam das Gefühl, du hast deinen Mischpult nicht unter Kontrolle.
Nein, mein Mischpult ist super.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Siehste, funktioniert einwandfrei. Bisher ist nur Nils fähig gewesen, Hallo zu sagen, beziehungsweise Nils zu sagen. Hallo Nils.
Also folgendes, ich wollte mal wissen, in welcher Höhe nun die Satelliten fliegen. Weil es hat ja auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass die irgendwann verglühen, nach 5 Jahren oder so.
Also es gibt also drei Klassen von Satelliten Orbits, die man unterscheidet. Das eine sind die Low Orbit Satelliten. Die fliegen halt ziemlich niedrig und die verglühen halt irgendwann. Auch ziemlich bald. Und das werden so glaube ich alle unterhalb 800 bis 1000 Kilometer werden als Low Orbit Satelliten geführt. 600 bis 1000, ja. Die Medium Orbit Satelliten sind so zwischen 5000 und 10.000 Kilometern. In den allermeisten Fällen sind das Kommunikationssatelliten. Die kreisen halt dann mit relativ langsamer Gemächlichkeit um die Erde. Und dann gibt es noch die geostationären Satelliten.
Die sind genauer 35.786 Kilometer.
Genau, was sagst du noch für geostationären Satelliten?
Ja, die haben eben eine Umlaufzeit von genau 24 Stunden. Und das ist eben erdsynchron. Und deswegen sieht es auf dem Erdboden so aus, als würden sich die nicht bewegen.
Also die kreisen sozusagen genauso schnell wie die Erde. Und das heißt, man hat den Eindruck, dass man, wenn man hochguckt, den Satelliten immer über sich hat.
Welchen sieht man denn überhaupt?
Eigentlich nur die Low-Abbot-Satelliten. Also die sind so, dass wenn die Sonne günstig steht, man einen guten Reflexionswinkel kriegt, dann sieht man halt die Reflexionen.
Na so wie mir oder so, die haben irgendwie Umlaufzeit von 90 Minuten.
Ja und wie ist es mit diesen Kommunikationssatelliten hier für Satellitentelefonen und so, wo sie jetzt so viele hochgeschossen haben, so 300 Stück oder so, wie ich da in der CT gelesen habe?
Also es gibt da mehrere Projekte. Am weitesten vorangeschritten ist...
Das machen wir dann gleich noch.
Ach so, ja, also wir sammeln das mal. Wir kommen da noch dazu.
Und Astra, Astra, 1A, B, C, D, E und so, die sind alle ziemlich weit weg, oder?
Die sind geostationär, weil du richtest dir deine Schüssel auf einen fixen Punkt, also einen für dich virtuell fixen Punkt am Himmel aus.
Also müssen die immer mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit wie die Erde.
Da ist es schon ziemlich eng mittlerweile bei den geostationären Satelliten. Also da gibt es so Slots und die werden dann richtig verteilt und so. Also das ist halt schon ziemlich Business.
Und das ist ja glaube ich auch ein Problem, immer die Satelliten so hoch zu schießen, dass die nicht mit anderen irgendwie zusammenstoßen. Weil es sind ja schon ziemlich viele, habt ihr ja vorhin schon gesagt, irgendwelche Schrauben und so, die da rumfliegen und wie 10.000 einzelne Teile da rumfliegen. Das ist doch eigentlich ein Problem, dass man da nicht zusammenstößt irgendwie.
Es gibt da so richtige Gürtel, die halt schon mit Schrott gefüllt sind. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass sie mittlerweile die letzten Stufen von den Raketen, wo die Satelliten denn drin sind und nur noch ein kleiner Treibsatz dran ist, dass sie die mittlerweile mit einer leichten Panzerung versehen, um zu verhindern, dass die halt, wenn sie durch diesen Gürtel fliegen, eine verpasst bekommen von dem Weltraumschrott.
So, Nils hat das vorgemacht, wie das geht.
Na gut.
Warte mal, hier könnte tatsächlich was falsch sein. Jetzt, in dem Moment. Siehst du? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hi Holger.
Ja, ich wollte mal fragen, bei diesen Low Orbit Satelliten wird es nicht ziemlich teuer, wenn die immer so schnell verblühen? Was sind denn das eigentlich für welche?
Naja, die Satelliten, die sie da hochschießen, die sind auch relativ preiswert im Vergleich zu großen Satelliten. Kosten die halt keine 100 Millionen, sondern die kosten nur so einstellige Millionenbeträge pro Stück. Und die haben so eine durchschnittliche Lebenszeit so zwischen ein und drei Jahren. Solange sind die halt da oben, aber die müssen halt so niedrig fliegen, damit man sie mit dem Telefon noch erreicht.
Und sie sind halt deshalb billiger, weil man eben auch sehr viel mehr davon braucht. Das heißt, es geht dann schon in so eine Art Serienfertigung über. Normalerweise wird halt dieser Satellit komplett neu entwickelt, ist natürlich teuer, und diese Kommunikationssatelliten, wo halt gleich irgendwie 50 bis 100 hochgeschickt werden, sind halt alle gleich.
Die kann man auch im neuen Conrad-Katalog bestellen.
Soweit kommen wir sicherlich noch.
Garantiert.
Wir gehen auf diese Kommunikationssatellitengeschichten, gehen wir nachher noch ein, aber vielleicht nochmal kurz, was du vorhin auch angesprochen hast mit der Administration und dem Problem, dass die Satelliten da oben so viel Platz verbrauchen. Also gerade diese geostationäre Position ist natürlich sehr gefragt, weil es eben ideal für Fernsehsatelliten ist. Astra ist da ein gutes Beispiel. Es gibt glaube ich sechs derzeit.
Es gibt 14 Astra-Satelliten und die Astra sind aber in so einem versetzten Muster geschaltet. Also die sind nicht alle aktiv, sondern die haben nur noch Spare-Satelliten um, die sie halt einschalten, wenn die anderen...
Du hast jetzt vor kurzem eine ausgetauscht worden, der die durch den E oder so.
Also wenn ich nicht richtig verstehe, dann ist sozusagen ein Buchstabe zwar ein bestimmtes Sammelsurium an Sendefrequenzen, aber es gibt mehrere Satelliten, die da einspringen.
Die stehen da auf der gleichen Position. Darum sieht man die auch mit einer Antenne.
Wie nah sind die denn?
Also so ein Grad sind glaube ich irgendwie 67, 5 Kilometer in dem Bereich, wo sich die aufhalten müssen, dass die...
Also der Raumwürfel ist glaube ich unter 100 x 100 Kilometer groß, in dem die Astra drin sind. Also ist ziemlich klein.
Wenn hast du gesagt, 15 x 15 Zentimeter pro Pixel, wie lange dauert es, mit anderen Worten noch, bis wir von Satelliten so beobachtet werden, dass man sehen kann, welchen Teller ich gerade abwasche?
Naja, das Problem ist letzten Endes, irgendwo kommt man an die physikalischen Grenzen. Also man kann halt irgendwann mit den... Also kommt man an die Grenzen der Lichtwellen auf die Entfernung. Und also ich sag mal, eine Auflösung unter einem Zentimeter erscheint mir nicht physikalisch realistisch. Also wenn du rote, grüne und blaue Teller hast, dann können sie es jetzt schon unterscheiden.
Sie kennen die Farbe deiner Teller.
Deine Teller.
Wir hören Chaosradio, den Computermoon, Blue Moon bei Fritz. Das Thema sind Satelliten und Fritz gibt's ja auch, Satellit europaweit zu hören. Wir können mal so ein kleines Spielchen machen. Wenn uns jetzt Computerfreunde und Computerkritiker zuhören oder Freundinnen und Kritikerinnen, dann würde uns mal interessieren, wer am weitesten weg sitzt und wer Fritz über Satellit hört. Komm mal jetzt auf einmal lauter Telefone. Gleich reden wir übrigens mit dem Chaos Computer Club, mit der Bay Area Abteilung. Aber erst mal gucken wir nochmal, ob es irgendwelche Satellitenhörer gibt. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hier ist Thomas aus Finsterwalle.
Thomas, Finsterwalle.
Schon ziemlich weit gesehen.
Du hörst mich über Satelliten nämlich an. Ach, tatsächlich. Einfach nur, du hast halt diese Schüsselstämme und denkst, du hörst über Satelliten, was dann wahrscheinlich besser klingt.
Analog oder digital?
Ich würde sagen digital.
Über Astra?
Über Astra, ja.
Was habe ich hier von Katrin habe ich hier eben.
Katrin.
Ich gebe mal kurz die Frequenz durch.
Wenn Fritz auf Satellit, dann Astra Digitalradio Transponder 30.
Siehst du, geht doch nur digital.
Ich weiß nicht, wir können doch mal ein kleines Experiment machen.
Ja, du machst laut und wir hören die Verzögerung oder was?
Na die ist 0, 7 Sekunden ungefähr.
Immerhin.
Ist meine Einwanderung noch vorne zurück halt.
Das lässt man hören.
Ja, 72.000 Kilometer ungefähr.
Sag mal was. Was ein tolles Echo.
Ich hab das mal ausgeschalten und ähm.
Hast du Rückkopplung oder was?
Naja, nee, die Rückkopplung gibt's halt nicht. Das ist halt durch die Verzögerung. Gibt's halt keine Rückkopplung. Nee, aber ich wollte mal was erzählen, ja, es wird vielleicht für euch ein bisschen peinlich werden. Und zwar, erstmal fangen wir an, der Sputnik, der hat keine Statusmeldung gemacht, wahrscheinlich doch, aber da hat durch die Internationale runtergefunkt.
Also, weiß ich nicht, ich erinnere mich da anders, aber ich weiß zumindest eine hübsche Urban Legend.
Nee, irgendeinen Gag hat der gemacht und der TV Sat 1, wo sie vergessen hatten, irgendwelche Klammern vorm Start zu lösen und drum gingen diese Solarpaneele halt nicht auf.
Das waren dann irgendwie, wir wissen nicht, 500 Millionen oder eine Milliarde halt.
Ja, diese Solarpanel-Ausfallgeschichte ist so ein ständiges Problem, das die da haben.
Mit den Klammern.
Ja, das ist ihnen sogar mal bei irgendeinem Spionagesatelliten passiert, das war ihnen ganz schrecklich peinlich, weil sie das vor einem Kongressausschuss begründen mussten, wieso sie jetzt gerade irgendwie 800 Millionen Dollar in den Sand gesetzt haben.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch was und zwar, die Geostationäre an den Satelliten kann man doch sehen.
Echt?
Ja, man muss einen kleinen Trick anwenden und zwar muss man eine Kamera nehmen und Langzeitbelichtung nehmen.
Stimmt, eine Langzeitbelichtung sieht man zwar, das sind die einzigen stehenden Punkte in dem Sternenfeld. Ja, genau.
Im Chat haben gerade Leute gefragt, von wem diese Musik kommt.
Das ist ein DJ Mixtape.
Wir können euch leider nicht sagen, von wem dieser Song jetzt ist, der gerade läuft. Aber eine Mail an chaos.orb.de wird zumindest Licht ins Dunkel bringen, wo diese DJs, die sowas mixen, vielleicht demnächst mal auflegen in Berlin. Und im Chat hat Bart gerade erzählt, dass er über die D-Box Fritz hört. Und jetzt ist Bart am Telefon. Hi.
Hallo. Moin Moin.
Jetzt wollten wir natürlich mal hören. Du hast nämlich im Chat geschrieben, drei Sekunden Verzögerung.
Ja, das hören wir doch mal.
Ja genau, lass mal hören. Drei Sekunden, da hat man ja ein richtiges Echo.
Ja, es dauert ziemlich lange, immer so.
Es dauert ziemlich lange, ja. Ich könnte mich praktisch nur eine selbst unterhalten.
Ich könnte mir eine Frage stellen. Johnny, wie geht's dir denn? Das ist genial, oder?
Das ist hübsch, ja, auf alle Fälle.
Sag mal, wo auf der D-Box ist denn der Fritz-Transponder?
Es sind ja jetzt ein paar Sender im Radio auch frei, also Fritz eins live und eine ganze Menge. Und das ist über Kabel jetzt die D-Box.
Du gehörst also zu den wenigen, die sich so ein Teil zugelegt haben? Ach mein, frate, hier war alles doppelt.
Kannst du mal die Parameter sagen? Die man da einstellen muss bei der D-Box und Fritze hören? Weil ich glaube, das ist auf dem Fritzer aber nicht korrekt.
Die Sachen werden automatisch gefunden. Also wenn die D-Box am Kabel angeschlossen ist, ist es eigentlich kein Problem. Die Sender werden alle automatisch eingestellt.
Also die sind halt im Radio-Setup zu sehen dann?
Vielen Dank für diese kurze Demonstration. Und bist du jetzt gleichzeitig noch am Chatten oder hast du nur eine Leitung?
Ich hab leider nur eine Leitung.
Ich muss jetzt leider den Chat verlassen.
Ah, das ist aber nett extra für uns, super. Dann sehen wir uns ja vielleicht gleich da wieder. Deine Nummer lösche ich natürlich jetzt wieder. Ist klar. Die Nummer von Bart findet ihr dann in den nächsten Videos an.
Nein.
Schöne Fun-Fahrer für das hier.
Wenn Fritz auf Satellit, dann Astra Digital Radio Transponder 30.
23 Uhr 31.
Waffenkontrollen. UN-Generalsekretär Anan bereitet die Inspektionen in acht irakischen Präsidentenpalästen vor. Die US-Regierung dringt darauf, das neue Abkommen mit Irak so bald wie möglich auf die Probe zu stellen. Kandidaten kür. Die SPD will einen Tag nach der Wahl in Niedersachsen über ihren Kanzlerkandidaten entscheiden. Parteichef Lafontaine hat den Vorstand für kommenden Montag zu einer Sondersitzung einberufen. Ablehnung, das Landesparlament in Brandenburg, ist gegen eine nachträgliche Änderung der Bodenreform von 1945. Den Alteigentümern dürfe der Rückkauf enteigneter Flächen nicht erleichtert werden, sonst seien die ostdeutsche Landwirtschaft und tausende Arbeitsplätze bedroht. Anstieg. Rechtsradikale begehen immer mehr Gewalttaten. Nach Erhebungen des Bundesverfassungsschutzes stieg die Zahl der Delikte im vergangenen Jahr um mindestens zehn Prozent. Prozess. Drei Monate nach dem Überfall auf einen 28-jährigen Ghanaer in Potsdam hat die Staatsanwaltschaft Anklage erhoben. Wegen schwerer Körperverletzung müssen sich fünf Jugendliche vor Gericht verantworten. Basketball. Das EM-Qualifikationsspiel der Männer in Stuttgart hat am Abend die deutsche Nationalmannschaft gegen Griechenland mit 74 zu 71 gewonnen.
Wette.
Nacht bewirkt aber trocken um fünf Grad. Morgen lockert die Bewölkung phasenweise auf. Temperaturen bis zehn Grad. Stadtautobahn Berlin Richtung Wedding zwischen Spandauer Damm und Siemens Damm ist die rechte Fahrbahn gesperrt.
Das war Gerald Kütterheinrich mit dem Fritz-Kurz-Info.
Er macht nur drei Shows in ganz Europa, aber eine davon in Berlin.
Wo sonst?
Iggy Pop.
Iggy Pop, live in Berlin. Die Show am 7. März ist ausverkauft. Daher gibt es ein Zusatzkonzert am 8.
März.
Ebenfalls in der Columbia Halle am Flughafen Tempelhof. Repräsentiert von Fritz.
Nur echt mit der Wollmütze.
Und nur echt mit dem Chaos Radio. Das ist die Sendung, die ihr hört, der Computer Club Moon bei Fritz, zu Gast im Studio wie immer. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat der Chaos Computer Club, der euch versorgt mit Infos zu neuzeitlichen Themen, würde ich einfach mal sagen. Heute geht es um Satelliten, der ihr die durften Zwischenfragen stellt, heißt meistens Johnny, die die zweitdürfsten Fragen stellen, seid ihr. Nee, die, die uns verbessern, seid ihr immer am Telefon. Die Telefonnummer hier ist 0331, für Podstern 7097110. Kann oft, dass man ein bisschen dauern, bis sie drankommt. Im Chat sind zwei Sachen angesprochen worden, die wir unbedingt noch behandeln müssen und die auch auf dem Zettel stehen. GPS auf jeden Fall, Global Positioning System und Watten.
Ich höre nichts.
Musst du deinen Kopfhörer lauter machen?
Hörst du nichts?
Lautstärke stelle ich meistens.
Kann er aber nicht wissen. Mike ist ja nicht zum ersten Mal hier, Frank und Tim wissen, wo die Lautstärke herkommt. Nee, das ist auch wirklich...
Ja, noch kurz zur D-Box. Da die D-Box ja ein nicht ganz unumstrittenes Gerät ist, haben wir uns natürlich auch damit beschäftigt. Und es gibt in der Datenschleuder Nummer 60, glaube ich, oder? Ja, 60. Genau, haben wir auch einen kleinen Bastelsatz veröffentlicht, mit dem man die Software in seiner D-Box, also nicht das Kryptomodul, sondern tatsächlich nur die Betriebssoftware, die halt diese ganzen Radiosender findet und so weiter und so fort, auch back-upen und wieder einspielen kann, falls der böse Onkel Kirch diese Software verändern tut. Die Informationen findet ihr auch auf dem CCC Webserver.
Datenschleuder gibt es übrigens in Berlin direkt zu kaufen. Übrigens auch die 60 und die aktuelle 61 bei JF. Lehmanns in Berlin in Hardenbergstraße. Da ist ihr immer vorrätig, auch die Chaos CD.
Das ist eine große Buchhandlung, die übrigens auch sehr gut ausgestattet ist mit Computerliteratur. Auch für Macintosh übrigens. In den meisten Buchleben, wo es Computerbücher gibt, da gibt es ja dann so eine Riesenwand für DOS und Windows und dann kommt hinten noch so eine kleine Spalte mit Macintosh. Und da steht dann drin Macintosh für Dummies und Macintosh für Einsteiger. Aber bei zwei drei großen Buchläden gibt es tatsächlich viel gute Literatur.
Wir wollten gerade noch über die schon angesprochenen Telefonsatelliten reden, die jetzt in großer Zahl um uns schwirren oder demnächst schwirren werden. Und dazu haben wir wieder unseren Experten vom Chaos Computer Club Berkeley, der uns erzählen will, wie es dann eigentlich mit diesen Telefonsatelliten aussieht, was die Kosten werden und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, Frank, es begab sich natürlich vor der Zeit, als die Nachfrage nach Weltfühlerkommunikation angeblich zunahm, die andere Erklärungsweise ist, der Kalte Krieg war zu Ende und die ganzen Unternehmen, die in diesem Bereich tätig werden, haben sich überlegt, wir müssen jetzt unser Geld irgendwie mit was anderem verdienen. Ja, und das Ergebnis dieser Entwicklung sind die GMPCS, Global Mobile Personal Communications by Satellite Systeme, die im Prinzip so ein Ziel haben, jedem von uns, der jetzt hier sich die Lande so schwört, sein eigenes kleines mobiles Terminal, etwa in Größe Standard-Mobiltelefonen in die Hand zu drücken. Und sobald er sich mal aus dem Bereich der heimischen Geliebten GSM-Netzdeckung entfernt, schalte das Gerät automatisch auf verliebten Funkern und ich bin selbst in der Antarktis, wo wir uns ja ständig aufhalten, ständig und überall erreichbar. Super praktisch. Ja, das ist tierisch praktisch. Es gibt aber auch tatsächlich einige Anwender, für die das jetzt schon sehr wichtig, sehr dringend ist. Die waren bis jetzt immer treue Kunden von so Firmen wie Inmarsat. Das sind insbesondere Journalisten, die ständig unterwegs sind, aber immer die gleiche Nummer haben wollen, ganz egal in welchem Krisengebiet sie sich gerade aufhalten. Hilfsorganisationen und halt sonstige Organisationen, Institutionen, die sich in entlegenen Gebieten auf diesem Erdbeil aufhalten. Das müssen jetzt nicht nur die berühmten Anarchist-Forschestationen sein. Es gibt auch unendlich viele Observatorien bis hinunter zu ganz simplen Dingen wie Truckflottenmanagement mitten in der Pampa in Argentinien, wo halt nun mal keine Telefonleitung ist.
Ich hab da neulich einen Artikel gelesen, dass auch weltweite Hilfsorganisationen verschiedenster Art daran ein großes Interesse zeigen an diesen Kommunikationssatelliten, da es in bestimmten Gebieten, gerade da wo Not am Mann ist, natürlich keine Telefonleitungen gibt und dass die da auch Geld investieren.
Die investieren natürlich nicht selbst, sondern sind halt die sogenannten Early Adoptive, also diejenigen, mit denen diese Netzbetreiber jetzt in der frühen Akzeptanzphase erstmal die ersten Testbasis, wie auch immer, Kunden haben. Und gerade Hilfsorganisationen, die sind natürlich sehr daran interessiert, weil die normalerweise, wenn sie einen solchen Einsatz haben, halt auf zerstörte bis schlecht nutzbare Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur antreffen. Und dann klappen die einfach entweder zur Zeit noch ihren kleinen Koffer auf oder demnächst ziehen sie halt nur noch ganz lässig das Handy aus der Tasche und sagen ja, so sieht's aus. Außerdem ist natürlich noch im Ziel Visier...
Die werden natürlich nicht sagen, so sieht's aus. Die werden sagen, okay, alles klar, wir telefonieren, okay, gut, ja, tschüss, bis denn.
Und sie haben häufig gesagt, das sind Sachen am Handy.
Ja und außerdem gibt es natürlich noch die Zielgruppe hier, der mobile Manager, der sowieso ständig rings um die Welt unterwegs ist und davon soll es ja auch ein paar geben und dann auch gerne bitte weltweit unter der gleichen Nummer erreichbar wäre. Das hat natürlich auch dazu geführt, dass ein wesentliches Paradigma, gerade bei den telefonorientierten Firmen, ist, dass das alles Dua-Band-Geräte sind. Wir sagen, zu Hause loggen die sich schön brav im GSM-Netz ein oder im DECT-Netz oder wo auch immer, wo sie gerade so lokal um sich herum existiert. Und wenn sie halt die Netzabdeckung des heimischen D-Netzes, C-Netzes, E-Netzes, C-Netz natürlich nicht verlassen, dann wird halt umgeschaltet auf Satellit und kostet dann auch dementsprechend mehr. Was kostet denn das eigentlich?
Kannst du mal was zu Preisen sagen, Björn?
Ja, genau. Und zwar, Preise schwanken. Die Idee ist, das Ganze einigermaßen preiswert um Dollar pro Minute anzubieten. Das Problem ist allerdings, wenn man jetzt irgendjemand darauf festnageln will, dann sagen sie, ja, ja, das ist jetzt der Text unserer letzten Presseerklärung.
Nichts genaues weiß man nicht.
Da ist viel möglich, ja, genau, nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Der Vorteil dieser Systeme ist halt, dass sie sich, und das ist eine sehr interessante Eigenschaft, wenn die Satelliten untereinander ausreichend kommunizieren können, muss man sich halt nicht mehr wie bisher erstmal über eine Ballstation runter ins Telefonnetz reinfräsen und dann von da im terrestrischen Telefonnetz weitervermitteln, sondern kann zumindest theoretisch weltweite Gespräche, weltweite netzinterne Gespräche über das entsprechende Satellitennetz führen. Und das ist natürlich für die Betreiber eine ganz interessante Sache, weil ein großer Teil der heutigen Gebühren im terrestrischen Telefonnetz kommt halt durch ein sehr schwachsinniges System namens International Accounting Rates zusammen, wo sie im Prinzip die Monopolisten hier anschütteln und sagen, also wie viel kostet das und das teilen wir uns jetzt aus. Ja, ein bisschen zur Technik. Sind wir schon so weit? Ja, dann sag ich mal, der Betreiber, der in letzter Zeit im meisten Publicity hat, aber gar nicht unbedingt der interessanteste ist, das ist Iridium. Dahinter steckt ein internes Konsortium, was von Motorola angeführt wird, das ist auch Low Earth Orbit. Und aus sechs polaren Orbits schießen die 66 Satelliten plus sechs Reservesatelliten ins All, davon sind es zwei Drittel, also 44 sind jetzt schon im Orbit. Die packen immer jeweils fünf aus einer Delta-2 Rakete drauf und schießen die übrigens auch alles hier in Kalifornien, Vandenberg Air Force Base, ab und sobald die dann eine gewisse Höhe erreicht hat, geht die letzte Stufe aus und die fünf Satelliten sollen idealerweise möglichst ohne Störung sich an ihre jeweiligen Plätze begeben.
Also wenn sie immer fünf hochschicken und jetzt 44 oben sind, dann muss ihnen ja schon einer abhanden gekommen sein.
Ja, ja und es gibt noch die Spares. Das ist auch sehr interessant, man hat also im Endausbauzustand noch sechs Satelliten, die einfach nicht genutzt werden, aber auf jeden Fall, dass einer runterfliegt, das ist ja schon nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen, dieses Risiko, fliegt halt der andere an die richtige Stelle, mal sehr salopp gesagt und das wird dann schon so funktionieren.
Aber die hat noch ursprünglich mal viel mehr Spare-Satelliten eingeplant, ne?
Iridium hat sich eigentlich immer so auf dieser Schiene so bewegt. Es gibt da noch andere Betreiber, da komme ich jetzt gleich noch zu, die haben noch wesentlich mehr, das ist richtig.
Das ist ja mit diesen Teledesic da von unserem Frontbild Geld.
Ja genau, also Betreiber wie Iridium, Globalstar, Ellipso, das sind, sag ich mal, Betreiber mit einer relativ überschaubaren Anzahl von Satelliten, also zwischen 66 für Iridium, Globalstar 48, Ellipso 17. Die bieten halt oder haben vor allem das Ziel, Telefonie und ein bisschen Daten. Und das ist wirklich nur ein lächerlicher Datenstrom. Also bei Iridium tröpfeln da gerade mal 2400 Bit pro Sekunde durch die Leitung oder durch den Aether.
Also nicht zum Klicken.
Ja, das ist überhaupt nichts zum Klicken bei Globalstar, idealerweise bis 9, 6 Kilobit pro Sekunde, aber das ist auch irgendwie kein Spaß. Das ist gerade mal was für E-Mail und heutzutage muss hier alles Multimedia sein. Und jetzt hier auftritt Teledesic in Gestalt von Craig McCaw, der früher einen Inhaber des größten amerikanischen Mobilfunkanbieters McCaw Cellular Communications war, bevor er eben diesen Laden an AT&T verkauft hat, weil ihm das zu langweilig wurde. Und was hat er gemacht? Naja, Teledesic. Und zwar zusammen mit einem anderen Herrn, der den eifrigen Hörern dieser Sendung auch nicht ganz unbekannt ist, und zwar Bill Gates. Ja, und Teledesic hat zum Ziel Fiberlike in Anführungsstrichen, also Glasfaser, vergleichbare Kommunikation weltweit überall, jederzeit. Was heißt das? Nun, die ursprüngliche Planung ging von Sargonschreiber 840, plus 84 Reserve-Satelliten aus, die also alle über einen Zeitraum von mehreren Jahren ins All geschossen werden sollten. Mittlerweile ist Boeing noch mit dem Boot und die haben dann erst mal den Jungs mit 840, wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ja die gesamten Startkapazitäten der Erde ausladen wird. Das schlagt euch mal wieder aus dem Kopf. Mittlerweile sind sie also auf 208 Sieg-Satelliten geeinigt, immer noch mit Abstand das größte Netz dieser Art und das Größnetz, was es jemals in dieser Art gegeben hat, wissen wir noch, ist hier noch nichts oben. Jede Satellitlebenszeit von etwa zehn Jahren, Systemkosten an die neun Milliarden Dollar. Ja, Daten, das ist jetzt die Frage. Neben normaler Telefonie ist das eigentlich nur ein Nebenprodukt. Die Terminals für Teledesics sollen mit allen möglichen Standards zusammenarbeiten, also die haben also eigentlich alles reingepackt, was irgendwie gut klingt, also IP, ISDN, ATM und was es sonst noch gibt. Was aber interessant ist, neben diesem 16 Kilobit pro Sekunde Datenkanal, sagen die halt wirklich, pass auf, ihr kriegt praktisch hier eure Datenleitung, Glasfaserqualität auch jetzt wie gesagt auch in die Sahara gelegt, und zwar nämlich bis zu 2 Megabit Uplink und bis zu 64 Megabyte Downlink. Ja, genau. Und das ist ja schon eine ganz nette Zahl und sie sagen auch schon, wir werden auch in absehbarer Zukunft auch Breitband Terminals haben, das heißt dann 64 Megabit pro Sekunde in beide Richtungen. Und das ist ja schon eine ganz nette Zahl. Das interessante an Teledesic ist, dass das ganze Netz ziemlich vollkommen anders aufgebaut ist als alle anderen Netze, die in dieser Art derzeit gebaut werden oder dabei sind in Betrieb zu gehen. Teledesic ist ein Paketvermitteltes Netz, also die Afrikaner, die diese Sendung wissen, wieder Paketvermittelt, also Internet-Technologie. Streng genommen erinnert es eher an ATM, also Zellen, die alle die gleiche Größe haben. Und diese 208 Astroniten bilden dann ein nicht chiragisches geodesisches Netz. Und jede Daten-Sendung nimmt praktisch ständig den Weg, jeder Satellit ist ein Node dieses großen geodesischen Netzes. Und jedes Paket nimmt ständig den Weg mit der niedrigsten Verzögerungszeit. Das setzt natürlich einige extrem komplexe Algorithmen voraus.
Und funktionierende Software ist glaube ich auch erforderlich dafür.
Funktionierende Software, richtig, richtig. Und es gab auch viele Zweifel, ob das jemals funktionieren wird. Na gut, the proof of the funding is in the EDing. Also mit anderen Worten, wir müssen erstmal noch warten, wenn das Ding oben ist, dann wird man sehen, ob es funktioniert. Aber ich hab mich mittlerweile überzeugen lassen, dass das technisch schon durchaus machbar ist.
Du hast dich überzeugen lassen?
Du warst doch nicht etwa in Redmond.
Nein, viel schlimmer. Aber ich hab mit dem Chef Internetarchitekten dieses von Teledesic, die sind auch nicht in Redmond direkt, sondern um die Ecke. Aber praktisch in Spukweite.
Wie machen die eigentlich die Kommunikation zwischen den Satelliten? Machen die Laser oder Funk? Also weil irgendwie gab es noch mal diese irre Annahme, dass sie es möglicherweise irgendwie im Laser tun würden.
Ja, ja, das Problem ist dann nur halt, da muss die Optik ja auch ständig nachgeführt werden.
Diese Nachführung kostet ja zu viel Strom, vermutlich mal, ne?
A, Strom und B sind auch wohl die Toleranzen nicht wirklich so, dass man sagen könnte, na gut, das wird schon irgendwie funktionieren. Also Funk ist einfach eine relativ erprobte Technologie. Andererseits muss man auch immer sagen, diese ganzen Design-Proposals haben sich jetzt allein in den letzten 12 Monaten schon so oft geändert. Man kann nie ausschließen, dass man noch irgendwas anderes einbauen, wo sie sich jetzt überhaupt nie von geredet haben. Auch Ellipso hatte erst mal von 10 Satelliten geredet, jetzt sind es auch 17, nachdem sie festgestellt haben, das klappt doch nicht so.
Also du meinst du, das ist noch nicht so weit ausgegangen, die Systeme?
Ja, also Teledesic hat immer noch das ehrgeizige Ziel, im Jahr 2002 an den Start zu gehen, aber das sind jetzt nur noch vier Jahre und ich werde erst mal zurückhalten.
Das klingt ein bisschen knapp, ne? Alles klar, okay. Ja, wir gehen auch gleich nochmal auf die Fähigkeiten dieser Netze ein, vielleicht auch GPS ein bisschen abzulösen, aber ich denke, wir machen jetzt erst mal wieder ein bisschen musikalische Pause.
Ja, Björn bleibt sowieso dabei und dann müssen wir auch unbedingt ein paar Fragen beantworten, weil die Telefonleitungen zwischenzeitlich immer wieder voll sind. So Jungs und Mädels, wobei das mit den Mädels ja doch immer eher mau aussieht bei technischen Sendungen. Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110 und Fragen stellen zum Thema Satelliten. Und ich verspreche jetzt gehen wir auch mal ein bisschen ran an das Telefon. Björn bleibt noch weiter am Telefon. Vielleicht kann er auch noch die eine oder andere Frage dann genauer beantworten, denn diese Sendung ist ja weltum spannend. Chaos Computer Club in Berlin, in Potsdam und in Berkeley.
In Berkeley, genau. Das ist vielleicht ganz interessant für die Leute, die uns auch in den USA hören. Es gibt ja immer wieder Deutsche, die da in dieser Computer-Gegend Fuß fassen. Wir haben so eine Art Nebenstelle in der Bay Area aufgemacht. Und der Björn wird uns sicherlich nachher noch mal eine E-Mail-Adresse durchgeben, wer also Interesse hat, mit den Leuten vom Chaos Club da in Kalifornien Kontakt aufzunehmen.
Oder wer eine kostenlose Unterbringung sucht.
Ich kann an Björn eine E-Mail schreiben.
So mal gucken, wer ist denn da jetzt am Telefon?
Hallo?
Hallo, hast du eine Frage?
Ja, natürlich, hier ist Marianne, hallo. Ich möchte nur mal folgendes wissen. Wie kommt das, dass Menschen Satelliten in den Weltraum schicken und denen dann suchen, den Satelliten?
Marianne?
Ja, das ist gewesen.
Schreiben wir uns auf und beantworten die gleich. Warte ich mal nochmal was dazu?
Also gut, oh Mensch, ob Mond, Mars oder Satelliten, bevor du bei deiner Forschung Millionen schießt sinnlos in den Sinn, forsche lieber, warum auf dieser Erde hungernde Kinder sind, pack deine Forschungsprogramme in den Schrank, forsche, warum die Umwelt auf deiner Erde krank.
Das war eine Lieblingsanruferin von WalterR42. 031-Post am 7097110, wenn ihr eure selbstgebaschelten Gedichte verlesen wollt. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaosradio.
Ja hallo, hier ist der Kai. Ich wollte eigentlich noch mal eine Anmerkung machen. Ich empfange euch auch über die D-Box. Und zwar ist das auf dem Astra 1G Transponder 119 im Paket von ARD digital.
Ganz einfach.
Aller, die jetzt D-Box haben, können das auf alle Fälle finden?
Ja, die Programme werden automatisch gefunden. Der legt die so ab.
Sag mal, du hast auch eine D-Box, nämlich deswegen.
Ich hab auch eine, ja.
Wie kommt ihr denn darauf, euch dieses überteuerte Scheißteil zu kaufen?
Du, ich hab gemietet. Ich habe das Ding gemietet. Ich hab da ja so viel von rumliegen und, weiß nicht, kann ich dann drei Monate ausprobieren und dann geb ich's wieder zurück.
Ach so. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie AOL.
Man muss alles mal ausprobieren.
Das finde ich auch, ja.
Eigentlich ist der Debug ein toller Computer.
Also das Ding ist nicht schlecht, was man damit alles machen kann.
Vorhin hat jemand gefragt, wofür der SCSI-Anschluss ist.
Da kannst du einen CD-ROM anschließen, kannst du mit Musik hören und wenn du die richtige Softwareversion hast, kannst du damit sogar Video-CDs gucken.
Genau, dafür ist das Ding.
Brauchst du aber dann einen DVD-Player?
Nö, da brauchst du ein einigermaßen fites, normales CD-ROM. Video-CD sind doch diese MPEG-1-Dinger, wo du zwei CD's für ein Spiel vom Brust hast.
Dann kann man hier diese Filme gucken, MPEG.
Ich meine, außerdem habe ich noch nie so viele begeisterte Hacker auf dem Card-Kongress gesehen, als irgendwie die inneren Eingeweide von so einer D-Box ausfällig erläutert hat auseinander. Also schon.
Warst du da auf dem Kongress?
Nee, ich war nicht da, aber ich hab das auch verfolgt im Internet. Und die deutschen Medien schimpfen alle, dass das eine veraltete Kiste wäre und unbequem und läuft nichts drauf. Und naja, also die Hacker, die sich damit befassen, die sind also absolut begeistert.
Endlich mal wieder ein Ziel für heute Morgen, würde ich sagen.
Vor allen Dingen auch ein echtes Ziel, ich meine, Kirch, Kinder.
Ja, und die Ratenkarten sind ja auch schon angeblich. Womit man ohne bezahlen gucken kann, aber na gut. Ja, was ich noch fragen wollte, dieses Iridium, dieses System, hallo, seid ihr noch da? Wunderbar. Die planen ja 66 Satelliten, habe ich gehört. Aber eigentlich kommt der Name von dem chemischen Element Iridium und das hat die Ordnungssaal 77. Und die wollten erst 77 Satelliten machen, aber da hat das Geld wohl nicht gelangen. Das klappt wohl nicht. Und ich habe gehört, 3 Dollar pro Minute soll es ungefähr kosten.
Den Preis habe ich irgendwie auch immer gehört. Also scheint mir auch realistischer zu sein als 1 Dollar.
Mobiltelefon meinst du jetzt?
Ja, das Satelliten-Telefon Iridium meint ihr.
Ja, und die sind ja momentan am dichtesten dran, in Betrieb zu gehen.
Ich kann es jetzt schon sehen in Neukölln. Ja, ich wohne da, aber da hat jeder zwei Handys. Ja, gibt doch eine Menge Freaks in dem Bereich. Und einige davon hören zu, das ist doch schön. Im Chat meinte gerade jemand, ich hab den Namen jetzt nicht. Ach da, Hennow meint MPEG-1 an der D-Box, ist Quatsch.
Na, was geht denn dann? Würde mich mal interessieren.
031-7-97-110. So, mal gucken, was wir noch für Fragen haben. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hier ist der Thorsten. Ich hab mal noch Fragen, sind denn diese Handys, die da eventuell konstruiert werden, die mit Satelliten kommunizieren, oder über Satelliten abhörsicher, wie es mit Fangschaltungen und so weiter?
Diese Firmen sind, wie Björn vorhin schon sagte, danach ausgewählt worden, dass sie alle gut Amerikaner sind. Also kannst du davon ausgehen, dass da irgendwie alle möglichen Anforderungen, alle Law Enforcement Agencies dieser Welt ausführlichst berücksichtigt werden. Das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass die Amerikaner es als politisches Werkzeug benutzen, um mal diese oder ihre Diktatur zu stürzen, indem sie halt irgendwie mal ausnahmsweise keine Bomben abschmeißen, sondern vielleicht mal so hunderttausend von diesen Sat-Linken-Handys.
Oder auch selektiv abschalten, ne?
Also die Abhörbar sind die Dinger halt immer. Also du kannst die zwar vielleicht möglicherweise etwas schwierig auf dem Funkwege abhören, aber ganz klar kann der Netzbetreiber irgendwie da Leitungen schalten. Interessant wird halt nur auf der Basis welcher rechtlichen Abkommen, denn zum Beispiel die deutsche Polizei Zugriff auf ein Telefongespräch mit einem amerikanischen Provider bekommt, da hab ich leider auch keine Ahnung.
Aber technisch ist es dann auch immer noch möglich.
Na klar, also die haben dann den Standards auch vorgesehen.
Du musst dir einfach klar machen, du kannst mit diesem Satelliten-Handy ja jedes beliebige normale Telefon anrufen, wo deine Sprache klar rauskommt. Mit anderen Worten, das Netz setzt an irgendeiner Stelle sowieso das Ganze klar um. Und wo sie das nun machen, das liegt völlig in ihrem Ermessen. Es gibt kein nicht abhörbares Telefonsystem auf die Zentrale. Ganz klare Aussage.
Hallo schreibt, dass dbox macht MPEG 1.5 und 2 und Power View.
Kann man nur so hinnehmen. Der dbox Experte ist nicht anwesend.
Ich hab da überhaupt keine Ahnung von der dbox.
Das bestimmt keinen überrascht so richtig. Hey, ja hallo, wir hören dich gut.
Wo bist du?
Ah, das klingt richtig scheiße.
Aber ich bin aber richtig bei Fritz, ja?
Ja, da bist du schon richtig. Du kannst ja kurz deine Frage stellen und dann...
Da war da ein ründerüstigter Funklaut.
Im Chat meinte gerade jemand, das wären Ortecre, die gerade laufen, die ich zwar kenne, aber von den Stücke nicht identifizieren kann. Könnte vom Sound her stimmen, aber wer weiß es schon. Das ist ein Mixtape von DJs, die sich Satellites on Safari nennen.
S-O-O-S.
Und das werden wir immer öfter haben hier im Chaosradio. So DJ-Mixtapes im Hintergrund. Die ganzen Störgeräusche von Handys und piependen Armbandhuren sind alle absolut beabsichtigt natürlich. Und authentisch. Und authentisch, denn das ist Chaosradio. Das Thema heute hier im Computer-Bloomoon mit dem Chaos Computer Club heißt Satelliten. Und ich glaube, was wirklich viele, viele Leute interessiert ist GPS, hauptsächlich fürs Auto wahrscheinlich. Aber wenn man mit seinem kleinen Pilot rumläuft und immer weiß, wo man ist, ist es natürlich auch nicht ganz schlecht.
Na ja, es gibt ja für den Pilot diese schöne Applikation, ja Soft GPS, die sagt dir in der Beschreibung für den Internet Download, wenn du diese Software installierst, brauchst du keine Hardware und dein Pilot sagt dir immer, wo du bist. Und wenn du diese Applikation startest, dann hast du ein großes schwarzes Kreuz auf dem Bildschirm, da drunter steht You are here. Ja, diese Positionsbestimmungsgeschichten sind auch einer der interessanteren Anwendungen für Satelliten. Derzeit gibt es ja zwei große Navigationssatellitensysteme. Das eine ist das GPS von den Amerikanern, das andere ist das GLONASS von den Russen. Die funktionieren ansatzweise ähnlich, sind aber alles so militär orientierte Systeme, die halt auch eine zivile Beikomponente haben. Und dadurch, dass die Empfänger mittlerweile immer billiger werden, findet man die an den Allmöglichen und Unmöglichen Stellen. Das Problem dabei ist, dass dadurch, dass die Dinge in den Händen von den Militärern sind, kann man sich dann nicht wirklich darauf verlassen, dass der Service halt auch dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, also im Krisenfall verfügbar ist, deswegen haben halt viele von den neuen Telekommunikations-Provider mit den Satelliten halt auch so eine Positionsbestimmungskomponente drin. Also die meisten von diesen Satelliten-Handys, wenn dann halt auch eine URL Funktion haben, die ja genau sagt, wo du bist, halt mit unterschiedlicher Genauigkeit dazu.
Schon erstaunlich. Ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass es vor vielen vielen Jahren, auch gar nicht so vielen Jahren, da gab es eine Volkszählung, gegen die sich ziemlich viele Leute gewehrt haben.
87.
Wo es denn 87 war das? Also vor genau elf Jahren, wo ein ziemlich großer Aufschrei durch die Leute ging. Was ich richtig richtig erstaunlich finde, ist, dass in diesem ganzen digitalen Bereich, also ob es mit E-Mail, Privatsphäre zu tun hat oder eben auch mit so Geschichten wie GPS, dass sich da scheinbar keiner mehr Gedanken drum macht. Wo sind denn die alle?
Sind die, die sich da Gedanken drum machen?
Ja, außer in Chaos Computer Club.
Ich glaube, die verdienen mittlerweile so genug Geld, sind irgendwie so dermassen arbeitslos, dass sie sich da keine Gedanken mehr drum machen.
Eins von beiden.
Also ich glaube, diese Positionsbestimmungsdatensätze, die wir uns noch mal so richtig viel Ärger machen, in den USA sieht man das ja noch wesentlich entspannter als hier. Da gibt es mittlerweile von General Motors ganze Autosälen. Wir fahren mittlerweile zwei Millionen von diesen Autos rum.
Die haben so ein System drin und heißt OnStar.
Da ist ein GPS-Empfänger direkt mit der Bordelektronik des Autos so intensiv verhekelt, dass sozusagen davon nicht mehr zu trennen ist. Und eingebaut in dieser Autoelektronik ist auch ein Funktelefon. Wenn du mit deinem Kreislader irgendwo gegenbrettest gegen den Baum und deine Airbags ausgelöst werden, dann wird die Zentrale verständigt, dass in deinem Auto die Airbagsensoren ausgelöst wurden über das Funktelefon und dazu wird deine GPS-Position übermittelt, die aus dem GPS-Empfänger. Und dann ruft dich die Zentrale über dein Autoradio, hallo, hallo, sieh, hören sie mich, hören sie mich. Wenn sie mich hören, dann drücken sie doch mal den großen roten Knopf da vor ihnen am Lenkrad. Und wenn du dann irgendwie nach einer Minute nicht antwortest, dann schicken sie da halt irgendwie das Rescue-Team raus, was sich denn aus deinem Auto sägen soll.
Das ist doch auch bei vielen deutschen Mietautos so, dass sie einen GPS-Empfänger haben.
Aber noch nicht mit dieser intensiven Verwebung in die Bordelektronik, die geht dann nämlich so weit, dass die die, die können dir einfach den Motor abstellen aus der Zentrale. Und wenn du irgendwie abends besoffen aus der Kneipe kommst, nicht mehr weißt, wo du ein Auto gelassen hast, dann packst du halt dein Funktelefon aus, rufst deine OnStar-Zentrale an und sagst ihm, die sollen mal kurz die Lichthupe in deinem Auto anmachen, damit du irgendwie dein Auto auf dem Parkdeck findest. Und wenn du dann festgestellt hast, dass du irgendwie so durch warst, bevor du in die Kneipe gegangen bist, dass du den Schlüssel im Auto liegen lassen hast, dann rufst du sie halt wieder an, wenn du vor deinem Auto stehst und sagst, sie sollen mal die Tür von deinem Auto aufmachen und dann machen sie dir halt die Tür von deinem Auto auf. Also das ist halt irgendwie unter dem Stichwort Sicherheit und Bequemlichkeit. Das akzeptieren die Leute halt wirklich jedes beliebige Maß an Überwachung.
Dieser Service kostet sich 3, 95 Dollar.
Genau.
Mercedes ist auch dabei, dass demnächst in die S-Klasse zu integrieren.
Den Web-Server.
Den Web-Server im Auto glaube ich noch nicht, aber zumindest diese komplette Servicegeschichte.
Sie können dann die exy-position auf der Erdoberfläche und die Höhe über 0 bestimmen, wobei bei den Zivilempfängern die Höhe über 0 immer...
Pi mal Daumen.
Naja, also die ist sozusagen nicht wirklich nützlich, die kann man dann nicht verwenden. Interessant ist, dass es halt irgendwie zwei Systeme gibt im GPS. Es gibt halt einmal das meditärische und einmal das zivile. Die funktionieren halt mit unterschiedlichen Codes, die man halt zum Empfangen benötigt. Und werden halt beide vom amerikanischen Militär betrieben, wobei das meditärische GPS deutlich genauer ist als das zivile GPS.
Das zivile ist wie genau?
Naja, also 80 Meter ist so...
100 Meter bei 95 Prozent war das irgendwie.
Ja, also so Erfahrungen zeigen, so 80 Meter kann man von ausgehen. Man kann das halt auch ein bisschen erweitern. Es gibt halt sogenannte DGPS-Empfänger.
Das machen sie zum Beispiel in der Schweiz bei so einem Flughafen, der zwischen den Bergen ganz gut versteckt liegt und der nur für kleinere Flugzeuge problemlos anfliegbar war und damit sie auch größere Maschinen reinbekommen. Bauen sie in das Flugzeug selber einen DGPS-Empfänger ein und der Flughafen selber sendet eben nochmal ein Differenzsignal aus. Das heißt, der Flughafen sagt eben auch ganz genau, ich bin hier. Und dann lässt sich eben allein auf rechnerischer Basis die Positionsbestimmung so genau machen. Also ich glaube, das ist dann metergenau, dass eben damit auch schon eine Navigation, ein mehr oder weniger Autopilot-Navigation des Flugzeuges möglich ist, um eben auch das Flugzeug da sicher runterzubringen bei jedem Wetter.
Also in Deutschland steht so eine offizielle Stelle, das ist in Mainflingen da auch, wo dieses Zeitsignal, dieses DCF 77 herkommt. Und mit diesem Signal hat man hier in Berlin ungefähr eine Abweichung von drei Metern. In Frankfurt ist es dann irgendwie 50 Zentimeter oder so im Dreh.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwie einen guten DGPS-Empfänger so für dieses Signal? Ist auch nichts, ne?
Teuer.
Also die Probleme mit diesen DGPS-Geschichten ist halt, die sind halt immer nur für eine bestimmte Region genau. Also die Amerikaner schalten ja das Signal von diesen Satelliten absichtlich unscharf, um halt irgendwie gegen Amerikaner gewendete Handlungen damit zu verhindern. Und womit man halt umgeht, ist, dass man halt einen Empfänger irgendwo hinbaut, an einer Position, die man halt sehr genau kennt, auf einen Meter genau, auf diesem Empfänger ebenfalls GPS empfängt. Und das vergleicht mit der Position, die man kennt. Und diese Abweichung schickt man dann per Funk raus, sodass alle anderen DGPS-Empfänger, also Differential-GPS-Empfänger, das bedeutet, die DGPS im Umkreis halt in der Lage sind, tatsächlich aus diesen beiden Signalen sich dann in genauer Position zusammen zu kombinieren.
Aber die muss doch wirklich genauer sein. Also wenn ich einen GPS im Auto hab und er sagt nächste Ecke rechts abbiegen, dann kann das nicht mit 80 Metern...
Na, das geht auch über deine Räder. Die haben da Sensoren dran, so wie es du fährst, und man kann da ihren Abgleich machen dran.
Also das funktioniert halt... Also mit dem Autolinnavigationsystem funktioniert das halt über eine Kombination. Also die haben halt den GPS für so grob, wo bin ich eigentlich? Dann haben sie eine Tricker-Navigation, die halt sagt, Auto fährt gerade nach links, Auto fährt gerade nach rechts. Sie haben Sensoren in den Rädern und zudem haben sie eine Straßenkarte, die da sagt, also du bist eigentlich auf einer Straße. Das ist sozusagen immer festgelegt, du fährst halt auf einer Straße, mit deinem Geländewagen hast du dann halt Pech, wenn du irgendwie nicht auf der Straße fährst. Und der malt dich dann halt immer auf die Straße, die im 20 Meter Umkreis von seiner Positionsbestimmung ist.
Komisch, was die so alles schaffen, aber mit dem 2-Liter-Auto, das kriegen sie eigentlich auf die Räume.
Absichtlich, ja klar.
So, Stefan fragt schon seit 28 Stunden, ob denn heute noch was zum Thema Amateurfunk-Satelliten kommt.
Haben wir hier auf der großen Liste stehen, die Oscars, ja?
Also der erste Oscar, der ist am 12.12.1961 ge-launched worden und hat eine Lebensdauer von 21 Tagen gehabt.
Ich meine, was macht ein Amateurfunk-Satellit?
Also der erste hat einfach nur Peep gemacht.
Der erste Transponder, dem ich da irgendwie was anfangen konnte, das war der erste, das war Oscar III, der wurde am 9.3.1965 ge-launched und hatte irgendwie 18 Tage Lebensdauer. Ich kann mich irgendwie noch erinnern in meiner Kindheit, ich war 13, das war 1976, da habe ich irgendwie Oscar achtmal gehört, wie der seine Telemetrie-Daten da runterfunkt, und da konnte man irgendwie einen HP-Taschenrechner irgendwie ausrechnen, dass irgendwie seine Solarzellen irgendwie jetzt gerade 12, 8 Volt liefern, und es war irgendwie total faszinierend.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt Mike losgetreten, ich glaube, jetzt geht es los, jetzt haben wir ein Törfondsateliet, mein Stichwort.
Ja, inzwischen sind wir glaube ich irgendwie bei Oscar 13, ich habe da irgendwie gerade die 30 im Film. Die Russen haben auch irgendwie Radio Sputnik, und dann gibt es irgendwie Japaner und Mexiko ist da irgendwie auch aktiv.
Wer schickt sie denn hoch?
Na das sind ja, also das ist einfach so gewesen. Bei der NASA sind irgendwie 99, 5 Prozent der Leute, die da angestellt sind Amateurfunker. Und dann gibt es immer irgendwie diese Driftlasten, auch wo die irgendwie ihre Rakete da ausgleichen müssen, dass die da nicht so nach rechts oder links kippt. Und da ist halt immer irgendwie ein paar Kilo Platz. Und da haben sich die gedacht, naja, da könnte man doch irgendwie so einen kleinen schnuckeligen Satelliten mit reinpacken. Und auch wenn der irgendwie bloß Piep macht oder man kann damit spielen.
Tja, Amateurfunker sind halt schon ziemlich verspielte Jungs, glaube ich. Also diese Driftlastgeschichten sind halt so die klassischen Startplätze halt für alle Leute, die eigentlich kein Geld haben, um Satelliten hochzuschießen. Das ist halt so, dass die Kommerzlernsatelliten, wenn die gebaut sind, dann sind die halt nie irgendwie genau austariert, sondern die haben auf der einen Seite die Batterie, auf der anderen Seite die Antenne und kippen halt immer so ein bisschen nach links oder rechts auf dem Starttisch. Und dann wird halt auf die andere Seite noch ein bisschen Gewicht reingepackt, um das halt auszugrechnen, damit man halt da nicht irgendwie Sandsäcke oder Bleiklötze hochschießen muss. Während halt mittlerweile bei nahezu allen Raketenunternehmen, werden halt diese Startplätze tatsächlich an Amateurfunker, Forscher, Unis und so weiter sofort vergeben, die dann halt ihre kleinen Satelliten hochschießen.
Stichwort Ablenktechnologien fällt hier noch?
Haben wir eigentlich noch unseren kalifornischen Berater?
Ja, der ist noch da, wenn er nicht eingeschlafen ist.
Ja, ich bin noch da.
Super.
Wir haben ihn dann gerufen.
Ablenktechnologie, soll ich da was sagen?
Ja klar.
Das wird natürlich sehr technisch, insofern will ich versuchen, das noch einigermaßen kurz zu halten.
Also Björn ist auch Amateurfunke.
Nicht ganz so schlimm. Zumal bei Teledesic läuft es so, dass die Kanalbündelung und Kanalteilung auch über Multifrequenz, Time Division, Multiple Access, also MF, TDMA, also ganz verspielte Geschichte, für den Uplink und für den Downlink nehmen sie asynchronous Time Division, Multiplexing Access, also TDMA, A für den Downlink. Jetzt hat das natürlich keiner verstanden, wenn der nicht weiß, worum es geht.
Nein, Time Division kann man ja mal kurz erläutern, ist, dass man einfach den Frequenzstrahl, den man außerdem in einzelne Zeitscheibchen verteilt und mehrere Nutzer sich jeweils einen Slot daraus herausnehmen, mal ganz einfach formuliert.
Ja, genau. Und für den Uplink machen sie halt außerdem diese Time Slots noch über mehrere Frequenzen verteilt und das ist jetzt bis jetzt halt sehr unüblich. TDMA ist halt eine Technik, die oftmals bei GSM verwendet wird und das dann noch über mehrere Frequenzen verteilt. Das ist ja nicht wirklich Spread-Spektrum, aber es ist schon hinreichend komplex, das ist schon eine sehr gute Frequenz-Outnutzung gestattet.
Die Jungs haben ja mittlerweile richtige Probleme mit ihren Satelliten. Ich hab neulich gehört, dass die auf den Uplinks von so normalen Fernsehsatelliten so an den Rändern von den Transponder mittlerweile irgendwelche Hacker haben, die da irgendwie richtig Spaß haben und halt so Datenübertragung mit ein paar Bits die Sekunde machen. Die nutzen sozusagen den ganz schmalen Raum am Rand eines Fernseh-Transponders aus und machen da halt irgendwie normale Datenübertragung drüber. Und in der Telesatellit, genau, in der Telesatellit ist so das Zentralorgan aller Satellitenfreunde, da war ein hübscher Artikel darüber, wie man amerikanische Militärsatelliten dazu benutzen kann, um halt irgendwie ein Radiosignal in alle Welt zu schicken, weil die halt die Transponder ständig offen haben.
Ja, soviel zum Thema dafür, es sind noch ein paar Stichworte gefallen, nämlich erstmal vielleicht ein paar Sätze zum Thema Internet über Satelliten. Wird wahrscheinlich aufs selbe rauslaufen wie telefonieren, ne?
Ja, das Problem ist irgendwie immer, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das bei Iridium sein wird und den anderen Netzen mit der Latency, weißt du das Björn?
Das Problem bei diesen Satelliten ist natürlich generell, je höher der Orbit, desto langer die Verzögerung, ganz logisch. Deswegen auch das für Geos und auch eigentlich Meos wie ICO ist das eigentlich alles nicht interessant. Und auch Iridium ist nicht primär für Daten gedacht, das ist mehr so ein nettes Beipackzettelchen. Also gerade Latenzzeiten sind wirklich schlecht, also für interaktive Applikationen ist das nicht der Hälfte, hat man es für den Durchsatz von seinen 2, 4 Kilobit pro Sekunden, aber bis der Durchsatz erst mal hin und zurück findet, das dauert seine Zeit.
Das ist die größte Masche am normalen Mobilfunk, das ist einfach irgendwie viel zu lange.
Ja genau. Wie groß wird das sein? Das ganze Netz hat das ganze Netz auch schon so konzipiert, zumindest um die Latenzzeiten extra niedrig zu halten, deswegen auch dieser sehr raffinierte Routing-Algorithmus, der also ständig sieht, was ist denn der Signalpfad mit dem kürzesten Delay, aber man kann sich natürlich nichts vormachen, das Signal muss, also die Physik bleibt trotzdem die gleiche, das Signal muss erst mal hoch und wieder runter. Die fliegen allerdings relativ niedrig, ich hab jetzt 1.400 Kilometer, glaube ich, das ist für Satelliten relativ wenig und es wird also um jeden Preis versucht, da die Latenz niedrig zu halten, aber da ist es natürlich trotzdem noch.
Eigentlich könnte man auch die Latenz gut unten halten, indem man einfach die Server hochschießt, oder?
Nach dem Motto, den Web-Server ins All, halb die Zeit gespart.
Genau, wenn man da ein Proxy auf dem Satelliten hat, dann kriegt man das doch ganz gut in den Griff.
Müssen noch eine neue Top-Level-Domain einführen, Punkt Satz.
Da lachen wir jetzt drüber.
Zweitens ohne. So ein Server in der Umlaufbahn hat natürlich den entscheidenden Vorteil, dass er irgendwie keinen nationalen Gesetzen unterliegt.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch das, was eben mal kurz zur Sprachkampfung ging abhören. Das Thema ist nämlich noch ein bisschen komplizierter. Letztendlich läuft es auch darauf hinaus, dass bestimmte nationale Sicherheitsorgane bestimmter Länder, um es mal vorsichtig auszudrücken, durchaus einen Vorteil der Informationsbeschaffung haben gegenüber anderen. Es ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass die amerikanischen Betreiber dem iranischen Geheimdienst gerne Tür und Tor in ihre Datenbanken öffnen. Umgekehrt ist natürlich auch Industriespionage und so weiter und so fort. Wird natürlich alles nicht richtig laut gesagt, aber da eröffnen sich schon interessante Möglichkeiten, insbesondere für die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, nicht wahr?
Also ich denke mal schon, dass die gerade bei ihren Providern sehr wohl dafür gesorgt haben, dass da die direkten Aufschaltanrichtungen für die NSA drin sind.
Jaja eben, aber halt auch nur für die.
Dann müssen auch viele deutschen Behörden anklopfen, bei der NSA um eine Mietergenehmigung beten.
Jaja, umgekehrt haltet die NSA auch die Möglichkeit, Gespräche abzuhören, wo sie bis jetzt in der Regel eher nicht die Möglichkeit gehabt hätten.
Wie sieht denn eigentlich aus, haben die da eigentlich Selective Availability eingeplant in diese Satellitennetze? Also dass sie über Bruma oder so abschalten können?
Ja das ist ein ganz schwieriges Problem. Also zum Beispiel ist es auch eigentlich mehr ein Gedankenproblem. Zum Beispiel ist es auch ja nach wie vor so, und daran haben auch die Regulierungsvorschriften nie geändert, dass also nach wie vor die nationalen, die jeweiligen Länder alles was irgendwie sendet, lizenzieren müssen. Also im Grunde genommen kann auch jeder Staat natürlich dir verbieten, ein Iridium oder sonst was Terminal innerhalb seiner Landesgrenzen zu benutzen.
Ja, dass er in Formen ein bisschen schwierig wird, ja.
Das ist aber praktisch vollkommen undurchsetzbar. Insofern versuchen sie aber gleich um eine einige Staaten, die das Banner dann nicht so hochhalten mit Telekommunikationsfreiheit und ja klar, gibt jedem Access, sagen sie uns mal, ja, ja, wir könnten da unter Umständen, wenn uns jemand bittet, die in Staat Nummer X, dann gucken wir uns die Position an, wurde ja schon erwähnt, die können so ungefähr wissen, also nicht nur ungefähr, sondern wissen relativ genau, wo das Terminal ist. Und dann sagen, ja gut, in dem Staat geht das dann halt nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich bis jetzt eher so ein Argument, um zu sagen, na ja, wir gehen schnell auf eure Bedenken ein und jetzt lasst uns mal machen. Ich glaube, ich würde nicht davon ausgehen, dass wir dann später auch wirklich dich da ganz erheblich drum kümmern, wenn sie da Geld mit verdienen können.
Na ja, gut, das Problem ist halt, dass schon heute tatsächlich diese technologischen Geschichten in Staaten wie China schon doch ziemlich aufmerksam betrachtet werden. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Chinesen das halt durchgehen lassen würden, dass da jeder Dissident irgendwie mit einem Telefon rumrennt, mit dem jeder ZZ hier ein Interview geben kann.
Ja, also man iologisch sicherlich nicht. Die Frage ist nur, wie man das technologisch verhindern kann. Das ist schon wesentlich komplizierter, insbesondere dann, wenn du nicht das... Also du könntest natürlich Peilung machen, aber... Ja, aber das ist schon relativ aufwendig. Vor allem, weil die Terminals ja keine so große Sendleistung haben.
Wie viel haben die eigentlich? Wie viel Watt gehen die da hoch?
Das, was wir sagen können, ist variiert. Das ist aber jedenfalls im einstelligen Wattbereich.
Ich bin ganz froh, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin, der gerade gegamt hat. Tim hat auch gegamt, ich hab's gesehen. Sag mal, kann ich kurz unterbrechen? Es kam gerade im Chat nämlich noch das Stichwort, kann man Satelliten hacken?
Oder habe ich wieder nicht aufgepasst, glaube ich.
Also es gibt schon Leute, die Satelliten Dxing machen, das haben wir vorhin schon gehört. Also Dxing bedeutet empfangen. Die also versuchen, entfernte Satelliten zu kriegen oder die zum Beispiel auch die Uplinks von Fernsehstationen mithören.
So Überspielkanäle.
Die Fernsehkanäle, die Fernsehstationen haben immer diese großen Satellitenautos irgendwo stehen und es gerade mal wieder irgendwo brennt und schicken halt das Signal erst mal hoch zur Fernsehstation. Da wird es dann geschnitten und von da aus gesendet. Und vom Satelliten runter zur Fernsehstation kann man mit entsprechendem Equipment auch abhören oder beziehungsweise absehen. Wie auch immer. Da gibt es Leute, die verbringen ja ihre Zeit damit tatsächlich irgendwie durch die Satelliten und durch die Kanäle zu surfen und zu gucken, was da gerade so runterkommt. Was weiß ich, ungeschnitten bei der Drogenaufnahme und so weiter.
So was hat man jetzt zum Beispiel in unserem letzten Club Discordia gesehen. Da hat man vom amerikanischen DX-Bank bekommen. Das war wirklich ganz lustig, was da so abging, mit Larry King und Ronald Reagan, was die sich da...
Um es kurz zu erläutern, sie haben sich halt einfach an alle möglichen Fernsehsignale ausstrahlende Satelliten rangehängt und einfach erstmal alles aufgenommen, irgendwie 500 Stunden Material und haben sich dann die Kante gegeben, das alles durchgeguckt und ein bisschen zusammengeschnitten. Interessant ist immer, also wenn eine Livesendung abgeht, dann bieten eben mehrere Satelliten, sogenannte Feeds, bieten halt ein Signal an, was dann eben erst ausgewählt wird in der Redaktion, je nachdem, jetzt soll das Interview rein, jetzt schalten wir den zu. Aber natürlich senden die natürlich vorher schon die ganze Zeit und man kann das einfach mithören, weil es in der Regel nicht verschnüsselt ist. Und so sieht man also Larry King, also der CNN-Moderator, zusammen mit Clinton, wie sie eben noch ein paar Sekunden, bevor sie draufgeschaltet werden, sich privat unterhalten und ja, und falls sie gewählt werden und...
Mein Boss, der unterstützt sie.
Ja, und sie wissen schon, nicht nur mit George Bush, als dass ich dann über die neuesten Psycho-Pharmaka unterhalten, die man so nehmen kann.
Er hätte da einen guten Apotheker bei dir, ey.
Ja, ja, ja, my friend is in the drug business. Also super lustig. Naja, wir hatten es, wir haben solche Videos, sammeln wir natürlich auch in unserem Archiv.
Und die wir dann auch ab und zu uns, solchen Donnerstagen, in unserem Club Discord ja zeigen.
Genau, das ist so das Ziel. Ja, sobald das Internet und die Modems das alles hergeben, denke ich, werden wir auch noch mehr Videomaterial im Netz haben. Aber derzeit ist es natürlich ein bisschen witzlos, weil damit macht man sich einfach immer alles pleite.
Ansonsten, was ich schon erwähnt hatte, die aktiven Hacker, die halt sozusagen die Bandbreite auf Satelliten illegal mitbenutzen, so im kleinen Rahmen, gibt es halt auch, also zum Beispiel gibt es halt amerikanische Militärsatelliten, die Fleetcom-Satelliten, die halt irgendwie ziemlich weit offen sind, also die ständig die Transponder aufgeschaltet haben. Das wurde halt zufällig entdeckt, weil irgendjemand auf so einem Satelliten irgendwie plötzlich Radio Innsbruck hörte und sich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen darüber wunderte, hä, Radio Innsbruck, auf dem amerikanischen Militärsatelliten, da stimmt irgendwas nicht. Dann haben sie halt ein bisschen geforscht und dann festgestellt, dass die dritte Oberwelle von Radio Innsbruck genau die Eingangsfrequenz von diesem Satelliten getroffen hat, der dann sozusagen Radio Innsbruck halt nicht so besonders guter Qualität, aber verständlich irgendwie über halb Südostasien ausgestrahlt hat. Und ansonsten finden sich halt auch irgendwie diverse Anwendungsmöglichkeiten für aktives Satellitenhacking halt auf den gängigen Fernsehsatelliten.
Es gibt noch zwei Fragen. Eine davon klingt erstmal ein bisschen blöde, finde ich aber überhaupt nicht so uninteressant. Wie groß ist denn so ein Satellit?
So groß wie eine Telefonzelle sind so die gängigen Angaben, die man so findet von irgendwelchen Satellitenherstellern. Also so zwischen Telefonzelle und VW-Bus sind so die.
So Astra ist irgendwie 3 auf 3 auf 3 Meter.
Und dann gibt es eine andere Frage, wie es mit der Kombination Deckt und Satt aussieht. Also DECT ist das System, was die...
Deckt ist eigentlich Todlorik. Also wenn man sich irgendwie anguckt, die Japaner haben ja PCS. Das ist ja die japanische Deck-Konkurrenz. Und die haben ja mittlerweile schon so 32 Kilobit Daten. Genau, die haben da schon 32 Kilobit Daten irgendwie zu den Telefonen. Und das funktioniert alles prima. Und irgendwie bei Deckt irgendwie kann man heutzutage noch keine funktionsfähigen Telefone kaufen, sondern die gröpeln alle vor sich hin und haben schlechte Software drin. Also die deutsche Industrie bzw. die europäische Industrie hat sich da mit Deckt ein richtiges Ei gelegt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es die Telefone...
Deckt ist das System, was benutzt wird für eure kabellosen Telefone. Und wie heißt das japanische System?
PHS, Personal Handyphone System.
Und warum gibt es das noch nicht hier?
Weil A, die Frequenzen, mit Frequenzen, B nicht richtig genug. Und B, die Vermarktostrategie in A ist ziemlich unklar. Also bis jetzt läuft das eigentlich nur richtig in Japan. Und hier hat natürlich die GSM Industrie, sag ich mal, Interesse daran, dass das GSM erstmal bestehen bleibt. Denn PHS ist schon ein bisschen mehr als nur Deckt. Also als ein rein lokal begrenztes Gerät. Es kann sich auch richtig schön von Zeller 1, Zeller 2 umbuchen und so weiter, so schnell, dass es nicht allzu schnell geschieht. Es ist also eigentlich fast eher eine Alternative zu einem Mobilfunk. Oder zumindest universeller als ein reines lokales Netz.
Aber ich glaube, davon wird in einer unserer nächsten Sendungen über Mobilfunk genauer.
Genau, das kommt nämlich auch demnächst. Und dazu passt auch der Kommentar hier im Chat, der durchaus stimmt. Warum heißt das Handy? Weil Handy ist doch tatsächlich dann auch nur die Deutschen.
Mittlerweile anscheinend schon, ja. Vielleicht heißt es auch in Wirklichkeit irgendwie, ist es irgendwann eine Abkürzung für ein ganz obskures japanisches Wort.
Für Hanyang!
Es gibt ja immer noch diese...
Genau wie auch GSM ja von Groups, das ja im Mobil plötzlich zur Global System von Mobile Communication mutierte.
Es gibt ja dann auch immer noch diesen bösen Schwabenwitz irgendwie, der eine dir ein Telefon gestellt und auspackt und sagt, du hast dein Handy da das Kabel vergessen.
Aber was man mal die Mehrbandgeräte angeht, also das ist schon eine ernste Sache. Und mit DECT ist es zwar so, dass diese Geräte bis jetzt eher noch alles in den Labors von Nokia und Co. rumhängen. Aber gerade GSM und Satelliten, das ist schon eine riesen Sache. Also ein ICO hat also schon fleißig Roaming Agreements mit allen schönen Unterzeichnungen. Das letzte war gerade hier mit der Schweizer PTT. Wer ist ICO? ICO ist einer von diesen kleinen Satellitenbetreibern. 10 Satelliten, 2, 6 Milliarden Kosten, Sprache mit 4, 8 Kilowitze pro Sekunde Daten. 2, 4. Soll im Jahre 2000 funktionieren. Und die fangen jetzt Ende dieses Jahres an, ihre Dinge hochzuschießen. Da steckt also Inmarsat und Youthspace hinter.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Datenbank über diese ganzen Roaming Agreements? Ich meine, die müssen mittlerweile noch richtige Probleme bekommen.
Datenbanken gibt es, die sind sehr groß. Das ist aber auch wieder kompliziert, weil das einige roben mit einigen, aber mit anderen auch wieder nicht. Das ist immer bilateral, das ist von Fall zu Fall anders. Apropos Datenbank, sollte man vielleicht nochmal anmerken, dass wir im Anschluss an diese Sendung ja auch den Chaosradio Ticker wieder rumschicken werden, mit vielen, vielen Links. Da gibt es unter anderem auch die MSL Spacecraft Library. Früher hieß das mal Mike's Spacecraft Library, weil sich da irgendjemand bei einer Nase halt einen Spaß draus gemacht hat. Mittlerweile haben sie das umbenannt, irgendwie Mobile Satellite Library, weil es jetzt offiziell ist.
Mobile Satellite Telecommunications Library steht hier.
Ja, wie auch immer. Und das werden wir noch umgeschickt und da kann man sich glaube ich ganz gut nochmal umtun. Und auch, wenn dir die Daten interessiert sind, sich da sicherlich noch einige Frauen ausziehen.
Und ansonsten für die Roaming-Geschichten, hier schreibt jemand www.gsmworld.com, wäre eine Adresse dafür. Und nach den Fritz Kurzinfo, kann man vielleicht noch auf die Frage eingehen, ob ihr irgendwas über World Space wisst, Radiosystem für dünn besiedelte Gebiete über Satellit ohne Schüssel. Und dann gab es noch die Frage, ne, Fragen nicht mehr.
Aber wir haben noch glaube ich ein bisschen Musik auf dem Raum.
Wir haben noch Musik und vor allen Dingen würde ich gerne noch ein paar Hörer nehmen. Das alles war den Fritz Kurz Info. Den hört Chaos Radio zum Thema Satelliten. Gleich gibt's mehr vom Chaosradio.
Wenn Fritz auf Satellit, dann Astral Digital Radio Transponder 30.
Null Uhr 31.
Waffenkontrollen. UN-Generalsekretär Anan bereitet die Inspektionen in acht irakischen Präsidenten Palästen vor. Die US-Regierung dringt darauf, das neue Abkommen mit Irak so bald wie möglich auf die Probe zu stellen. Revolte in einem Gefängnis der albanischen Hauptstadt Tirana haben Gefangene einen Aufstand angezettelt. Dies verlautete am Abend aus dem Innenministerium. Die Insassen hätten sich aus ihren Zellen befreit und in einem Saal des Gefängnisses versammelt. Kandidatenkür. Die SPD will einen Tag nach der Wahl im Niedersachsen über ihren Kanzlerkandidaten entscheiden. Parteichef Lafontaine hat den Vorstand für kommenden Montag zu einer Sondersitzung einberufen. Ablehnung. Das Landesparlament in Brandenburg ist gegen eine nachträgliche Änderung der Bodenreform von 1945. Den Alteigentümern dürfe der Rückkauf enteigneter Flächen nicht erleichtert werden, sonst seien die ostdeutsche Landwirtschaft und tausende Arbeitsplätze bedroht. Anstieg. Rechtsradikale begehen immer mehr Gewalttaten. Nach Erhebungen des Bundesverfassungsschutzes stieg die Zahl der Delikte im vergangenen Jahr um mindestens 10 Prozent. Prozess. Drei Monate nach dem Überfall auf einen 28-jährigen Ganaer in Potsdam hat die Staatsanwaltschaft Anklage erhoben. Wegen schwerer Körperverletzung müssen sich fünf Jugendliche vor Gericht verantworten. Basketball. Das EM-Qualifikationsspiel der Männer in Stuttgart hat am Abend die deutsche Nationalmannschaft gegen Griechenland mit 74 zu 71 gewonnen.
Wette.
Heute Nacht bewölkt aber trocken um 5 Grad die Temperaturen dabei. Morgen lockert die Bewölkung auf Temperaturen bis 10 Grad.
Verkehr.
Da habe ich keine Meldungen und wünsche weiterhin eine gute Fahrt für euch.
Tatsächlich?
Wo ist denn der Zettelverdarm?
Kurz mit dem Fritz. Kurze Info.
Fritz wird fünf und präsentiert die Tournee. Die Tournee der 5 Jahre Fritz Radioshow mit Mike Lehmann, Susanne, Tommy Wosch, Kuttner, Cumanschenberg, der Alten Frau, Ursel, The Glorious Fritz-Five featuring Breakin Phil und der Ein-Mann-Showband namens Hobo Space und ganz speziellen Special Guests.
Tja, das könnt ihr natürlich auch gerne machen, aber nicht mehr als 120K. Da fragen jetzt natürlich alle im Chat, wer war das, wer ist das? Und das ärgert mich persönlich ein bisschen. Das ist aber reiner Neid, denn da muss ich euch auf eine Homepage von einem großen Multimedia-Institut verweisen, www.lava.de. Da sind unter anderem Leute von Pixel Park bei. Und Aaron König selbst, einer der Chefs, singt auf diesem Lied, schick mir deinen GIF, das gibt es auch auf Englisch. Schick mir ein GIF.
Chaosradio möchte da gerne noch eine Empfehlung abgeben.
Wir machen da einen schönen Chaosradio-Internet-Song und der wird anständig klingen, nicht so wie so ne... Machen wir den? Ja, wir machen das. Nicht so wie so ne hier, na.
Wir werden uns noch nie dran erinnern. 3 Mio.
Kaffee-Pausen-Band. Da werden Gitarren drin vorkommen und Elektronik.
Gibt da ja morgen ein interessantes Ereignis irgendwie. Dann steht jemand sozusagen zur Wahl des Hacker des Monats. Oder vielleicht sogar Hacker des Jahres.
Das Monat.
Weil er eine Institution...
Social Hacker sozusagen.
Weil er eine außerirdische Institution Deutschlands oder Europas hacken wird. Wie wir hoffen. Mal gucken, wie es ausgeht. Dieser Oberschnulzenmeister Gildo Horn steht morgen im Tett zum Telefonwahl als Kandidat für den deutschen Beitrag für den Grand Prix. Der Eurovision de la Chanson. Ihr kennt das sicherlich im Fernsehen. Und wir würden euch empfehlen, dort eure Stimme entsprechend abzugeben.
L'Allemagne 12 points. Ja, Gildo Horn versucht zu irgendwie den Grand Prix der Eurovision zu finden.
Wie heißt denn die Band vollständig?
Gildo Horn hat die orthopädischen Strümpfe.
Genau, die orthopädischen Strümpfe sind es glaube ich. Alle Links zur der Grand Prix Homepage findet ihr auf Chaosradio ccc.de.
Auch hier fragt jemand über welchen Satellit der Fritz-Menü, der Satelliten-Menü funktioniert. Keine Ahnung.
Ein Eutelsatt.
Eutel? Ist ein Eutelsatt.
Das war klar.
Echt, was eine Frage. Eutelsatt natürlich.
Es gibt doch übrigens in Berlin gerade im Museum für...
Für Verkehrentechnik. Da gibt es eine aufstehende Geschichte. Die war als in Nürnberg. Genau, da hab ich die, glaub ich, mal gesehen. Das war ganz lustig.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach eine Geschichte von Satelliten sagen?
Von Satelliten, ja. Und da kann man sich so einen Satelliten auch mal angucken. Da haben sie so ein Demomodell, mit dem sie irgendwie mal alles durchproffiert haben. Also so ein Zwillingsbruder von einem Satelliten, dass man sich das mal angucken kann.
Was ist das Museum noch?
Museum für Verkehr und Technik.
Das ist ein Museum für Post und Telekommunikation.
Das ist nicht im Verkehr und Technik.
Das ist ein Museum für Post und Telekommunikation. Das ist noch bis 12. oder 13. März. Ich glaube, die ist empfehlenswert. Die sollten wir uns eigentlich auch angucken. Hätten wir eigentlich vor der Sendung machen sollen.
Nachher weiß man immer alles besser.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt zum Schluss noch ein bisschen die Telefoner auf. Dann haben wir ein paar abschließende Fragen zu haben. Das hab ich mir gedacht, dass der Kollege aufgelegt hat. Der hat nämlich seit einer Stunde langsam auf der Leitung liegen.
Der Ärmste.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Eine Ergänzung, und zwar habt ihr vorhin über Internet, über Satellit gesprochen. Und da gibt es auch eine Sache für Europa. Moment, jetzt müssen wir kurz nachschauen. European Satellite Multimedia Services. Interessant daran ist, dass Intel da seine Finger mit im Spiel hat. Und zwar zusammen mit Astra. Die wollen, glaube ich, soweit ich das weiß, so ein Business-Internet-Anschluss für Firmen hauptsächlich bereitstellen. Das ist auf der Cebit letztes Jahr vorgestellt worden. Ich habe da leider nichts mehr von gehört.
Es gab einige von diesen Satellitenproviderplänen, die Internet über Satellite realisieren wollten, die aber im Laufe dieses Jahres durch terrestrische Billig-Anbindungen auf Kabelbasis weitgehend geschlagen werden. Wir können dieses Jahr damit rechnen, dass ADSL-Technologien, wo man ein paar Megabit aus der Telefonsteckdose rausbekommt, verfügbar sein werden in Europa bzw. in Deutschland. Die dürften dann doch erheblich preisgünstiger sein als diese Satellitensservices.
Aber in der Pampa? Es geht ja um die Pampa. Da haste nicht 3 Sdl, 6 km da.
Ja gut, mobil sind diese Geschichten ja auch nicht, sondern die beruhen ja schon auf einer festen Schüssel. Die haben meistens so einen Meter, 1, 50 Meter Schüssel. Da gab es irgendwie diverse Projekte, irgendwie von Olivietti und von...
In dem Fall war es so, dass es ein kombiniertes Projekt war. Das heißt, dass du sozusagen in die großen Strecken wie ein Satellit überbrücken konntest und dann aber z.B. den Uplink später von dir aus wieder über den Boden.
Über das Grabe gemacht.
Da hast du irgendwie down, dann wird es 34 Megabit und irgendwie was anderes machst du, du bist hellgeräuscht.
Mehr nur, dass du heute 34 Megabit nicht für dich alleine hast. Deswegen ist es nämlich eine Rechnung.
Ja, und einer von euch hatte vorhin auch noch gesagt, dass es vorher noch nicht so weit wäre, Webseiten auf dem Auto abrufen zu können. Also zumindest weil sich das Citroen sowas baut und Mercedes baut sowas auch, und zwar den sogenannten Cyber-Mercedes, wo also mehrere Bildschirme dann auf dem Auto sind.
Aber nur auf den Rücksätzen.
Ja, und das ist, weiß ich, das ist insofern fand ich ganz witzig, weil ich in der Meldung gelesen habe, dass Mercedes da den Fahrer von seiner kommunikativen Isolation befreien wollte. Da stand dann so eine Presseinfo drin und darüber konnte ich mich ganz gut amüsieren.
Super, das Einzige, was ich an der Fahrt von Berlin nach Potsdam nett finde, ist, dass ich irgendwie mal eine halbe Stunde so für mich bin.
Die ruft sich da keiner an?
Nee.
Zumindest nimmst du nicht ab.
Doch, leider ja.
Na ja, ansonsten gibt es ja für den Fahrer demnächst auch das Hits-up-Display, wo er dann einfach beim Blick auf die Autobahn noch irgendwie die Webseiten in die Windschutzscheibe eingeschpiegelt hat.
Wollte ich gerade fragen, was eigentlich daraus geworden ist. Da hieß es ja mal, dass sowas nicht so sehr ablenkt. Wobei, wenn ich mir vorstelle, man spielt irgendein Autorennspiel dann da drauf. Das wäre schon eine interessante Kombination.
Ich glaube mal, nach Geschwindigkeit und Uhrzeit ist das, was die meisten Leute sicherlich da haben wollen, ein Fadenkreuz eingeblendet in die Windschutzscheibe.
Wahrscheinlich, ein Steuerbares.
Dafür ist auch sehr interessant diese sogenannten Wearables, wo du zum Beispiel das Bild direkt auf die Netzhaut spiegeln lassen kannst. Das ist Autofahren.
Ja, aktuelle CT.
Genau, richtig, habe ich auch gelesen.
Solche Dinge wären natürlich mit satelitenbasierten Datenservices erst richtig interessant, wenn man tatsächlich in einer Pampa sitzen kann und irgendwie nichts weiter bei sich haben muss und trotzdem klicken kann.
Das wäre für mich schlecht.
Klicken in der Wüste.
Am besten noch mit der Pupillenposition, dass man sich das einfach nur noch anschaut und anblinzelt und nicht mehr klicken muss.
Ja, war es das erstmal? Übrigens wollte ich mal sagen, dass diese Sendung immer höchst aktuell ist und es soll sie regelmäßig hören, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat bzw. jetzt nächsten Monat im März findet sie dann ein bisschen verschoben statt nämlich am 1. April, was uns natürlich total freut. Denn am letzten Mittwoch im März sind die CCC-Jungs noch bei der Cebit. Und die Aktualität dieser Sendung ist mir neulich aufgefallen. In der letzten Wired Ausgabe nämlich gab es einen großen Artikel, der eigentlich nur, haben die natürlich nicht von uns abgeguckt, ist schon klar, aber der eigentlich eine Sendung reflektiert hat, die wir hier auch mal gemacht haben, nämlich Information Warfare sozusagen. Also wir haben schon mal darüber berichtet, wie Kriege der Zukunft aussehen könnten. Und Wired hat das natürlich populistischer aufgezogen. Also die haben so ein gefaktes, so eine gefakte Presseberichte gemacht und E-Mails und so weiter, wie das aussieht. Das ist richtig schlecht. Ich hab's nicht ganz gelesen, irgendwann hat's mich gelangweilt. Wobei ich sagen muss, dass wenn man sowas so aufzieht, was natürlich eine Masse mehr Arbeit ist oder so, ist es natürlich durchaus nicht unspannend.
Es war wieder mal so ein typisches Wired-Teil. Sie haben sich da so einen Typen gegriffen, der solche Geschichten die ganze Zeit auf irgendwelchen Konferenzen erzählt. Und haben ihn gebeten, das mal in zehn Seiten zusammenzuschreiben. Also der Typ, der inhaltlich voran von diesem Artikel, der springt schon seit Ewigkeiten auf diesen Information Warfare Konferenzen ran.
Sowieso finde ich das Wired eine Zeitschrift, die immer anstrengender wird. Vorletzte Ausgabe, diese Jubiläumsausgabe, hat mich wirklich fast dazu getrieben, irgendwie dahin zu schreiben und abzubestellen. Weil da waren echt ein paar so dermaßen dumpfe Geschichten drin, gerade zum Thema Gentechnologie, die ich wirklich richtig haarsträubend fand. Also ansonsten, ich finde, wenn ihr und vor allen Dingen auf Deutsch, wenn ihr was wirklich Gutes lesen wollt, was sich mit modernen Technologien auch auseinandersetzt und auch mit moderner Musik, dann...
Lies die Datenschleuder.
Und Debug. Großartiges Magazin.
Debug? Ja, also ich hab in die Debug auch schon mal reingeschaut. Das ist eigentlich eher so eine Technoszene, mit mehr Internet als bisher Anteil. Ich hab mir das nicht komplett durchgelesen. Die Berichte jetzt über die Szene sind ganz gut. Letztes Mal ein schöner Bericht über Chile und so. Die beleuchten ganz interessante Aspekte. Allerdings ist so ihre Netzredaktion noch ein bisschen überarbeitungswürdig. Das war alles etwas unvollständig. Und die Tipps waren ein bisschen inakkurat. Vielleicht legen wir dann einen etwas hohen Maßstab an. Das mag schon sein.
Aber es sind interessante Tränen. Ich finde es deswegen super interessant. Die Musiksachen, außer die Interviews und so, über die das sind ja auch oft bekanntere Künstler, also die Plattenkritiken zum Beispiel, kenne ich einfach zu wenig von oder weiß ich nicht. Da müsste ich zu viel Geld ausgeben, um das dann tatsächlich anzuhören. Aber was da politisch so und von Netzkultur her beleuchtet wird, finde ich äußerst spannend und interessant. Für einen Magazin, was du eigentlich umsonst in Plattenläden mitnehmen kannst und so.
Ja, sie haben auch eine URL, allerdings ist es mir noch nie gelungen, diese Webseite mal hochzubringen. Du hast sie erreicht. Ich hab sie dreimal probiert, war immer down.
Nee, die ist extrem langsam leider, weil sie unglaublich viele Frames hat.
Frames, Frames, Frames.
Als ich sie das letzte Mal gesehen hab, hat sie zumindest unglaublich viele Frames.
Ich kann dir die URL mal durchsagen, das ist www.de-bug.de Ja, kann sein.
Irgendwann war ich mal unter Buzz, aber Buzz gibt's halt schon. Deswegen mussten wir auch den Namen ändern und so. Jedenfalls, also ich finde dieses Magazin äußerst empfehlenswert. Und man muss natürlich in jeder Zeitung oder in jeder Zeitschrift nicht alles so nehmen, wie es da geschrieben wird. Und man kann sich ja auch dazu äußern. Das ist ja das Schöne an E-Mail, dass das auch alles recht flott geht. Aber so der Großteil der Artikel gefällt mir äußerst gut.
Es gibt ja auch noch so eine deutsche Wired. Also vielleicht ist das nicht der richtige Name.
Die Sternenzeitschrift? Die ich nicht so richtig scheiße finde, muss ich sagen.
Schön bunt.
Für Deutschland ist das ganz gut.
Und das weniger hyper hyper als Wired, von daher ist es ganz angenehm zu lesen.
Das ist doch auch die Geschichte um das deutsche Wired gewesen, oder das die ja gar nur über...
Das ist eine endlose Geschichte.
Junge Amerikaner schreiben, die mit einer cleveren Idee auf einmal zum Multi-Millionär und Manager geworden sind. Und das hat dann... Ja, das Tape ist zu Ende. Das hat dann irgendwann der Verlag hier gesagt, dass es in Deutschland nicht funktioniert. Ja, Wireds, teilweise ärgerlich inzwischen, finde ich leider auch.
Die neuen.
Die neuen willst du hören? Jetzt hab ich gerade schon was eingesehen.
Kontrastprogramm.
Was ist das denn jetzt? Ich hab gerade Musik laufen hier. Ja, ich hab mal Musik von Chaosradio 23 noch mal eingeschaltet.
Da hast du dich eben auch schön ausgesperrt. Das ist nämlich als kleine Anmerkung zu dem Danube-Ensbrich. Es ist so, dass diese Dinge tatsächlich, die haben das hier ein paar Meter weiter südlich. In Kalifornien haben sie auch ein Silicon Valley, auch hier ein nettes Testzentrum für sowas. Das Ding hat einen Web-Server eingebaut, das ist kein Witz.
Ein Server?
Was surft das? Keiner weiß, wozu es richtig sinnvoll ist und wird wohl auch nie so rauskommen.
Man kann den Vergaser einklicken.
Das dann hat keine Homepage mehr, sondern eine Carpage.
Super.
Wenn wir erstmal zum Thema Autos kommen.
Die Position ist interessant. Stell dir vor, die persönliche Tim-Homepage sagt dir, dass Tim irgendwo in Potsdam sitzt und kann Chaosradio machen.
Ich sehe keinen Grund, warum ich meinen Webster wenn ich auch noch am Gürtel tragen soll.
Dann hab ich noch Platz. Na, knapp Nötte.
Na ja, schon voll.
Darf halt nicht so groß sein.
Also dann können wir anfangen, die Plätze von unseren Gürteln zu vermieten.
Alle zwei.
Bevor uns die Gesprächsthemenkarten ausgehen, vielleicht noch zwei, drei Hinweise. Es gibt da auch noch so eine Software, mit der man selber sich über den aktuellen Stand aller Satelliten schön informieren kann. Muss zugeben, dass die Funktion der Software nicht genau erkennt ist, heißt Satellite Toolkit STK.
Das ist aktuell in der Version 4.0. Das gibt es für Unix und die Microsoft-Plattformen. Also das ist sozusagen die Software, die die Jungs auch in diesen Kontrollzentren benutzen, wenn man dann da irgendwie die Mir oder den Spaceshuttle, der da so auf die Erde abgebildet ist, machen die auch mit diesem Satellite Toolkit. Das Schöne ist dadurch, dass ein großer Teil dieser Software mit amerikanischem Regierungsgeld angeschrieben wurde. Es ist halt ein großer Teil der Software frei. Es gibt halt ein paar Module, die kommerziell sind. Aber das ist sozusagen die Referenzsoftware, die man benutzt, wenn man halt irgendwie alle Möchensatelliten-Geschichten abbilden will. Die Daten gibt es halt vom NORAD, frisch vom RADA. Interessanterweise werden bei den NORAD-Daten halt die Spionagesatelliten ausgeblendet. Die kriegt man halt nicht. Die gibt es ja in allen Stellen im Internet.
Erstaunlich. Überraschend, wenn ich das sage. Überrasch dich, ne?
Naja, also man kann sich da schon ein bisschen Transparenz verschaffen, wenn man Lust dazu hat. Ja?
Was machst du denn heute Abend noch in Berkeley?
Von Abend ist nicht die Rede. Es ist jetzt 10 Uhr.
Jaja, deswegen frage ich, was du heute Abend noch machst.
Ich bin sinnlos zu saufen natürlich.
Ahja, na ist doch schön.
Ich bin doch froh, dass man nicht extra nach Berkeley muss.
Die zahlreiche Hörerpost, die ich heute Nacht noch ankomme, will ich alle extra für euch bearbeiten.
Ach so, genau. Dann sag doch mal, wo wir dich e-Mail technisch erreichen können.
Ja genau, der Kontakt für CCC Berkeley wäre mal ganz interessant.
Ja, der CCC Bay Area, wie er mittlerweile heißt, also wer sich demnächst in der San Francisco Bay Area in Nordkalifornien umtut, E-Mail Kontakt geht über br.ccc.de und einen Webseller werden wir irgendwann hoffentlich vielleicht irgendwann auch mal haben. Und etwa, ja.
Habt ihr mittlerweile schon einen regelmäßigen Treff?
Wir haben einen regelmäßigen Treff.
Dienstags?
In San Francisco.
Nicht Dienstags, sondern jeden Mittwoch im Monat. Und wir hoffen, dass wir demnächst auch eine Datenschleudertour veröffentlichen, samt PO-Box und allem, was man sonst noch so braucht.
Wie wird die dann auf Englisch heißen, die Datenschleuder?
Datenschleuder, das wird dann in der amerikanischen...
Das ist ein Markenname, das kennen die Leute hier auch.
Genau.
Dann schicken wir mal die Termine, weil die nächste Datenschleuder ist sozusagen schon in Vorbereitung.
Ja, ich weiß, das hätte ich schon letzte Woche machen sollen und so weiter und so fort, aber wir wollen eigentlich halt noch Web-Server und Schnickschnack und so, bevor das irgendwie in die Presse läuft.
Habt ihr eigentlich auch schon lokale Teilnehmer?
Echte Amerikaner, ihr werdet nicht glauben.
Aber ehrlich, das ist doch höchst. Björn, vielen Dank und schönen Gruß.
Ja.
Bis denn. So, das hat den ORB jetzt, wer weiß nicht, wie viel, 1000 Mark gekostet, aber hey, wer weiß, wie lange wir das hier alles noch machen. Was hören wir da gerade im Hintergrund?
Wir hören das Tap von Chaosradio 23, noch mal so ein Teil als Füller von Dawn Stone.
Zum Abschluss der Sendung wird es übrigens was von Zupfgeigen heißen.
Wir hatten übrigens heute keine Kurzmeldung, die sind irgendwie ein bisschen unter die Räder gekommen, aber eine schöne Meldung haben wir noch.
Hacker für freies China, München. Die chinesische Hackergruppe Hongkong Blondes hat sich mit der in den USA ansässigen Hacker-Vereinigung Kite of the Dead Codes zusammengetan. Gemeinsam wollte man für die Einhaltung der Menschenrechte in China einstehen, so ein Sprecher der Gruppen. Diese Woche machte das Gericht in der amerikanischen Presse die Runde, die chinesischen Blondinen seien in einen Kommunikationssatelliten der chinesischen Armee eingedrungen. Diese Aktionen habe demonstrieren sollen, dass die Gruppe ernst genommen werden muss.
Das alles ist noch sehr unbestätigt.
Stand im Internet.
Alles ist wahr. Ja, also vielleicht mal so zum Ende nochmal die Einladung. Wir sind auf der CeBIT und würden euch gerne auf der CeBIT treffen. Ansonsten gibt es morgen im CCC Berlin den Club Discordia, wo jeder kommen kann. Ihr könnt auch eure Rechner mitbringen, wenn ihr ein E-Mail-Card habt. Und da machen wir so ein bisschen ein gemeinsames Treffen. Letztes Mal waren wir noch ein bisschen unterbesetzt. Gucken, ob sich das diesmal ändert. Der Donnerstag ist auch nicht so ein idealer Termin, aber morgen würden wir uns freuen, euch zu sehen. Vielleicht kommen auch die, die schon mal da waren. Und auf der CeBIT haben wir halt den Stand. Und am Chaos-Dienstag, also am 24. März, machen wir das große Treffen auf dem Microsoft-Stand in Halle 2.
Und da könnt ihr euch nochmal darüber informieren, auf den Seiten www.cct.de. Denn da solltet ihr alle selbstgebackenes mitbringen. Und Pinguine. Zum Thema Hippies und Computer gibt es dann gleich nochmal Zupfgeigenhansel zu hören. Wie kommst du denn bitte auf Zupfgeigenhansel?
Kontrastprogramm.
Ja, das Kontrastprogramm finde ich immer größer.
Ist das das Lied für Marianne?
Das ist sozusagen mein Lied für Marianne.
Ist klar.
Dann der Night Flight mit Martin Pedersdorf. Kannst du früher anfangen, Martin?
Ne, das wollen wir hören.
Du musst dann auch 2-3 Minuten ausfüllen.
Ja, das könnte man vielleicht noch einwenden. Ich hab hier noch die Notiz. Es gibt ja dann auch noch, die haben wir für dich rausgelassen, diese Wettersatelliten, so Meteosat und Freunde.
Da gibt es dann auch diese Bastelfreunde. Das ist gar nicht so groß der Aufwand, irgendwie diese schlechte Auflösung von den Wettersatelliten selber zu empfangen. Die guten, ausgewerteten Karten, die werden ja erst einmal nach unten geschickt, werden aufgearbeitet.
Die Opus rausretuschiert.
Genau, und dann werden sie wieder hochgeschickt und dann erst Frage gegeben.
Was braucht man, um das zu empfangen?
Eigentlich braucht man nur einen Scanner und eine mittelordentliche Antenne. Genau, es gibt mittlerweile praktisch alle die Modasoftware für diese Dinger.
Das ist eigentlich wie Fax, also.
Und sie schicken das auch nur wie einen TIFF oder G3 Fax.
Genau, das heißt.
Das ist halt so ein Fax-Format.
Das heißt, wenn man dann einen richtig großen Bildschirm hat, dann kann man sich abends für die Freundin zu Hause davor stellen und so diese Handbewegungen machen. Und sagen, so, hier oben sehen wir das Hoch, Johnny, das uns ein wunderbares Wasser beschert. Und hier unten, ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass die Hochs immer Männernamen haben und die Tiefs immer Frauennamen?
Das ist aber so eine Ruhl, irgendwie, bei den Meteorologen sind halt mehr Männer.
Übrigens, mir geht gerade, was ja bei Computerthemen ganz anders ist, mir geht gerade per SMS noch eine Randnotiz ein bezüglich diese Web-Servers in dem Daimler. Der ist für die Wartung des...
Bestimmt kann man auch tunen im Tiefen-HTML.
Also da fährt also ein Daimler Benz durch die Gegend und während man durch die Gegend fährt, klickt irgendein Techniker mit einem Daimler Benz.
Na, die können viel ein bisschen optimieren und neue Software einspielen.
Rebooting-System bei 150 Km auf der Autobahn.
Das wird schade eigentlich, dass ich Satellite of Love nicht mit hatte als Stück.
Hätte auch gut gepasst. Naja, müssen wir halt mit Zupfgeigenhansel aufhören. Es war eine schöne Überleitung für den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf, der auch großer Zupfgeigenhansel Fan ist.
Er war übrigens damals schon im Zupfgeigenhansel Fan Club.
Erster Vorsitzender, hat alle T-Shirts, hatten die überhaupt T-Shirts? Unglaublich.
Du hast ein schönes T-Shirt an, Karte.
Ich hab ein Chaosradio T-Shirt an. Das könnt ihr übrigens bestellen. Krieg ich davon was ab eigentlich?
Ja, immerhin hab ich das Logo gemacht, zur Hälfte.
Du hast doch schon ein T-Shirt bekommen, Johnny.
Ich hab immer gesagt, da muss ein Griff dran, aber...
An das Radio oder an das T-Shirt?
An das Radio sonst.
Stimmt, wir können es nochmal überarbeiten. Das ist dann die erste limitierte Auflage.
Aber ein Radiomoderator mit Griff zum Wegschmeißen...
Wäre auch eine nette Idee.
Genau, gerade wenn der Fusion irgendwie hier ansteht von den Radiosendern.
Was für eine Fusion?
Ist das mit Chaosradio Schluss? Das wisst ihr dann, ne?
Echt?
Ach, scheiße.
Chaosradio gibt es nur bei Fritz.
Oh man, nur echt?
Naja, dann müssen wir die halt verhindern.
Wir müssen halt ein eigenes Satellit noch schicken.
Nur echt mit Chaosradio und Zupfgeigenhansel. Das war's.
Habe Kommentare an chaos.orb.de Schickt uns URLs, schickt uns Kommentare zu den Sendungen. Wir möchten gerne hören, wie ihr das findet. Und ansonsten kommen wir jetzt noch zu dem Lied von Marianne und wir verabschieden uns bei euch das Chaosradio Team.